Which was really that excited.
Yes.
Hello,
any.
I'm good.
How are you?
A sports sunglasses.
I like those glasses.
Glasses,
sunglasses.
This is.
This is how I look in your face.
Well thanks.
It's a good choice.
We do have been flirting with me since I
arrived.
A little bit casual.
Nothing weird.
Just the way you button that shirt all
the way up to the top.
That little top button.
The Jean Jacket,
that Jay Leno's garage.
Look.
Yeah,
I just came from dot Levins podcast.
So,
uh,
we were just talking about the fights.
I'd stopped you before we actually
talked.
We were just feeling like,
like this is more evidence that we are
living in a computer simulation.
Like everything is getting weirder.
Politics is the most bizarre.
I mean it's,
everything is falling apart and it's
like the Matrix.
Programmers can't keep up with the code.
Do you think that maybe like when one or
two things go weird,
like the election?
I think the election,
I think having a reality star television
host guy who's a media mogul become the
president of United States is so odd to
people that I think it gives us this
feeling of instability and that feeling
of instability,
instability has like a ripple effect and
it starts to fuck with all these other
aspects of our reality and then these
blurbs just start popping up and these
weirdnesses what's Kinda like rather
than it being a proof that it's a
simulation.
This is the most reality we've had in a
long time.
Right?
Like we've all been living in this like
pseudo thi this theater of stability,
that hype.
I'm sure you've talked about
hypernormalization on this podcast
before having to.
I think the documentary,
it's real good if people haven't caught
up to it yet.
It's on youtube and in its entirety,
it's dense.
It's not like a light.
It's not a light fun documentary is like
a three hour long British guide droning
on too,
like found footage on pvc.
But his basic point is that,
you know,
society is unstable and has been for a
very long time.
That greenland is melting,
we have nukes second,
destroy us at any point,
and there was no way for the leaders to
actually run a functional and stable
society.
So what they do instead is they put up
this artifice of stability.
Meanwhile,
shit is fucking collapsing behind the
set and basically prove out example uses
the Soviet Union,
right?
Is like Soviet Union stopped working
almost immediately,
right?
They,
they tried this utopic communistic
beautiful society and everything fell
apart immediately.
Everybody knew what fell apart.
Everyone in in,
in,
in Russia knew it wasn't working,
but it,
it served them more to pretend that it
was working.
And so people got into this willful,
a sort of voluntary suspension of
disbelief.
This voluntary cognitive dissonance to
like say,
oh no,
everything's good.
Even though they go to the fucking the
store,
there's no bread.
They would just get.
Everybody was walking around as if it
was real.
So maybe when somebody like trump gets
elected this fake realness of like
everything's good Americans.
Awesome.
What a wonderful place.
A utopic society with all these
freedoms.
Maybe that rips the seam.
Then Anthony Rumble,
Johnson retired from MMA
or something.
Wow.
Where do you go with that?
I think
there's always been problems with
society,
right?
I mean,
if you go back to ancient Rome,
you know,
have you ever visited the coliseum?
Yeah.
Fascinating.
Right?
It crazy.
Yeah.
And when you think about it,
that's only,
you know,
you're only talking about a thousand,
2000 years ago,
right?
Like when did,
when did it all start in Rome?
Rome was around for,
for 2000 years.
Right,
right.
I mean there were like 10 times as long
as this American superpower has existed.
So.
Yeah.
And they were.
But the thing is they didn't have the
technology to strip mine the world the
way we do technology has now caught up
human evil or whatever it is,
or human avarice has always been
probably equal.
Right?
But my point was that there's never been
like any example of a society or a true
Utopian society that was like really
together,
very relaxed.
People are Nice.
There was no war,
there was no crime,
there's no rape.
There was no stealing.
The best example of that is hippie
communes,
right?
Because they're specifically designed to
create a mini utopia and they always
fall apart with a guy at the top.
Fucking everybody flies every time.
It's never not happened.
A friend of mine's ex-girlfriend grew up
in one of those and she was so fucked up
because of it.
They're always fucked up.
Yeah.
They're all the best you'll ever get out
of a guy or a girl that grew up in one
of those communes is like,
um,
it was in,
there was some really good parts that's
as good as you can get.
Yeah.
And that's someone that's just really
kind.
Yeah.
I mean they,
people always try to reengineer cycling.
I was,
I was reading something today about,
um,
a free housing that free housing should
be a universal right for people that
everyone should have free housing.
You know,
and I was reading this was taking a shit
so I didn't go into it too deeply,
but that immediately I was thinking,
well,
who's gonna build the housing.
Like how is that a right?
Like,
it can't have a universal.
Right?
If some people just don't want to build
a house and they don't want to work and
they don't want to do anything and they
want somebody else to build a house for
them,
that's always going to be a possibility.
Like.
Sure.
Yeah.
Right.
I mean,
I guess.
Right.
But what are rights rights are
completely constructed,
right?
I mean,
sure,
a lion has no right to loan that.
That should be a right,
but the right to privacy rabbit of a
lion or a ape has no rights.
It's just an ape getting eaten and
fucked by its neighbor.
Right?
So we decided what rights are so that.
So the same idea that says something.
Anything is a right.
You could also say,
yeah,
housing is a right.
If,
if society deems that that's true,
I guess.
Or if society has the resources,
we do have the resources.
That's true of right.
I think yeah,
I would.
I would imagine we have the rights or
the resources rather than how's
everybody in the car?
Not In the best way.
Not a sweet apartment,
but you know what I mean.
Just a roof over your head.
Warmth.
Yeah.
I think like the idea that we were
getting way into the theoretics of
taxation and civil responsibility,
but like the idea that we spend
trillions of dollars on a protective
military when we are,
we've lapped every other military so
many times over.
Like we could everybody,
every homeless person.
I mean there are countries where they
don't have homeless people,
right?
They just don't know.
I've been in Israel and it's like people
who are homeless in Israel or there are
homeless because they're crazy and want
to be homeless or my,
my brother was just in um,
uh,
one of those,
one of those super white countries,
Switzerland,
I think it was Switzerland.
And everybody was like,
yeah,
we don't have.
I mean,
this is crazy.
What he told me,
he was like,
what's this,
what society?
Like you're like,
it's cool,
you know,
we don't have like a poverty.
So that's cool.
Like they don't have poor people.
Yeah.
That's not a part of their society.
Is that Switzerland?
Is that.
What is that?
I think it was Switzerland.
They have,
they figured out a way to make money on
the Bank of Denmark is Kinda like that
too.
Yeah.
I mean northern Europe,
they,
they've done something right.
I think.
Well,
I think they're also dealing with a very
small population of people that have
existed for a long time in the same
place.
Right.
And you kind of normalize and they've
never conquered their conquerors,
you know,
they're not spreading their resources
thin across the globe,
making battleships and shit.
Right.
I was thinking about you on the way over
here.
I think this is connected.
I was thinking about you and the
flirtation we were going to be doing and
I was wondering,
because you're bent,
I've watched her stand up since trump
got elected and you and a lot of the
guys at the store or I would say I've
always taken the store,
like a libertarian,
a intellectual epicenter of comedy.
Right.
And then like if you go to go east it
becomes more and more like socialist
further to travel.
Right.
And um,
I guess what I'm the hot,
it's like the neocons,
but at any rate,
um,
I would say your bent is like,
everything's fucking fine.
You're,
you're crying,
you're making a crisis that doesn't
exist.
And I was wondering,
do you still think that it's not
necessarily really my bent,
it's the way that it works now.
That's a real comedian.
Yeah,
the community as well.
Actually I believe it's just one of the
things that I say on stage.
Like I say,
like,
um,
like a lot of the stuff I say it was
fucked up.
So if I say anything that's,
that you don't agree with,
I don't agree with a lot of Shit I say,
but it's funnier than when I agree with
like some of the things I say clearly
fucking around.
And then some of the things I say it's
like where's he,
is he on the fence on this?
But what a lot of it is,
is just to set up this idea that the
whole system has always been
preposterous.
Totally.
It's just that it's weird.
It's almost our fault,
right?
Because he'd take a guy like a Clinton
or a guy like an Obama who's fairly
successful at the job and people are
just constantly trying to find chinks in
the armor,
constantly trying to find cracks in who
he is.
And it was Clinton and obviously it was
the philandering with Obama.
There was a chink,
the size of a pussy.
Chinks sounds like a weird word to use
even if you're not using it.
And erase the word niggardly got in
trouble for saying niggardly.
Yeah.
And they were like,
you can't say that word.
It's like,
but it's not even etymologically
connected to the n word.
And we were like,
we don't care.
It's spelled differently.
Not the same root word that like,
don't use it,
but I feel that way about swastikas.
Do you know those hippy swastikas and
the Indians Swastika and all these
hippies and am like,
you know,
Buddhists are always like,
yes,
it's a different spots to cuts a special
swastika,
the good swastika.
It's like the good witch and the bad
witch from the wizard of Oz.
And I'm like,
alright,
that's cool Buddhist,
but I think you should just abandon the
good swastika.
You gotta own.
You've got other shit you could do.
It was a symbol used in Okinawa and
karate.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Actually it's made its rounds.
Right?
Because he was in India,
in,
in a Hindu temples,
Okinawa.
Maybe that's Buddhism,
Hinduism to Buddhism to karate.
I like that.
I don't know where,
where,
why it was in there.
But I remember seeing it a long time ago
in a store like this Okinawan karate
book.
And there was this like these symbols
and I was like this bizarre,
like a swastika is a part of karate,
but it might've been reversed,
you know?
Sometimes they do it the opposite way,
but yeah,
that's symbols gone.
You got to let that go.
Well let's just abandon that one.
Then you could walk away from that with
you got other symbols.
It's like a lot like the Hitler
mustache,
like there's no need.
I mean look,
chaplain suffered,
but no,
I bet Mr. Mr Miyagi was like,
you know,
wax on,
wax off,
put that swastika on your shoulder.
Isn't it funny that you could just
stretch that bitch just a little bit and
you're okay if you just trim it just
light.
Oh,
you're talking about.
But yeah,
as long as it's not the actual Hitler.
If you just stretch it slightly towards
the corner of your mouth,
you just keep going.
Just bring that bitch back like this.
You're okay.
I thought you were being so vulgar for a
second and that you just had the most
like pornography pornographic thought
ever.
That crazy.
If you just stretch that bitch just a
little bit,
you're just.
You're okay.
Just stretch it.
Stretch it.
But his mouth.
I was thinking about a pussy.
No,
no,
no.
Wow.
That's weird that you just went there
and we're talking about Hitler's
mustache.
Well,
I get turned on.
When I think about the Nazis,
I got a real,
like some of the synopsis in my Jewish
Brain got cross.
She called that desk the next special
mouth.
Fucking Hitler
stretching Hitler's mouth.
But isn't it a weird thing like that
mustache,
like it's.
There's a certain amount of space it can
cover on your lip and it's okay because
as long as it goes far enough left and
right where I.
Okay.
You know,
I mean the Hitlers haircut is making a
huge comeback.
That's right.
And people get in trouble for that
haircut.
I was the first guy,
I mean I was on the first wave,
I would say I was in the,
not the first right of hipsters
reclaiming that haircut.
Well it's like a longer on the side,
write longer on the side,
sort of puffy on the top.
I mean it's,
you got rocky hit late night.
I used to know this.
This is,
I've changed since because it got too
cool and I truly am a hipster.
I follow,
I follow where the trends go,
but I used to have a,
I used to have a bit about it,
about the dilemma that a Jew has when
he's telling a barbara what he wants.
And the only,
the quickest way to describe it,
it's just to say Hitler.
So you want something,
you know,
like a kind of old timey,
kind of a like a military cut like
Hitler,
the destroyer of my people make me look
like him.
And then the punch,
the tag was as my grandparents turned
over and they're shallow unmarked
graves.
Anyway.
Yeah,
let's start.
it was dark.
But my point was originally,
not really that I had a point,
but when we chipping away at this thing,
like we know that politicians are doing
an act.
We know that there when,
you know,
I've always mocked the way they
communicate,
like the way they give speeches,
the long pauses in this very distinct
pattern of behavior that's completely
alien to anything other than a political
speech.
Like the only way this country survives,
you know,
like that kind of the strange thing that
they do.
But when,
when we're always like chipping away at
that,
we're always trying to like get to like
be real key.
We gotta get,
we gotta find out what's real and then
we get this guy who realer than anyone's
ever been.
Yeah.
And we're like,
well fuck this,
this is crazy.
And it scares us.
That's the point of that documentary we
like to be lied to.
It makes us all feel calm and
comfortable to be given a stable lie
than to be shown the real truth of how
fucked up and unstable everything.
Yeah,
I mean the.
The trailer has this text over over,
just like stock footage.
It's just.
And it's so scary.
It's the words are a politicians lie to
us.
We know they lie,
they know,
we know they lie,
they just don't care.
And I just always sent chills down my
spine because it's so true and everybody
knows it.
And yet we're all engaged in this
willful suspension of disbelief.
Like,
no,
everything's good.
You know?
No,
both America's both the greatest country
on earth and it needs to be made great.
Again.
It's like we're all in this weird,
like we're unclear on what were even
arguing for.
It's almost like what trump's done is
put a totally new engine in the heart of
the car.
It's like if you have an old car like
Washington and it relies on a combustion
engine and then someone comes along and
puts an electrical engine and then
you're like,
whoa,
Whoa,
what are you saying?
You don't need congress anymore.
You don't need the Senate.
You don't need this.
You don't need that.
You don't need the cronies.
You don't need the lobbyists.
You have this whole new system and you
don't need to pretend to talk like that.
Even more importantly,
you don't need to do the theatrics
anymore.
You can be a real,
the real terrible person who always wore
and everybody goes along with it.
That's the weirdest thing to me about
this election is not the president
himself,
excuse me,
but how many people on line who you've
never seen politically engaged are now
in it like like a,
like a sports fan?
You know?
I do understand well to the people that
hate trump.
I understand because what it did was
it disrupted our programming on such a
profound level that people.
I was talking to somebody last night
that said that it was much more
disturbing when trump got elected.
Then nine slash 11 was to them,
and I understand that sentiment because
nine slash 11 was a terrible event.
This feels like a terrible new chapter
in American history,
but nine slash 11 happened while Bush
was in office and Dick Cheney was the
vice president.
He was one of the scariest guys to ever
have no doubt,
and that is the.
I mean,
I think the best point that you're
making is like Dick Cheney's pretending
that he's stable while meanwhile he's
like Japan stowing evil in to bombing
Iraq and you know,
do you want a guy that makes you feel
somewhat comfortable and stable?
Who is actually the most evil Satan
fucker in the world or a guy that makes
you feel the evil but isn't as bad.
Way more transparent.
His motivations.
I mean,
Cheney was the ceo of Halliburton and
then all sudden Halliburton wants to
bomb Iraq.
You know,
he does rather they get these billion
dollar,
multibillion dollar,
no bid contracts to rebuild what they've
bombed and you're like,
Jesus Christ,
a little kid can connect the dots here.
This is,
this is insane.
I always just wonder what,
how much money do you want?
I never quite get it like you're willing
to just in.
It just seems too simple to me to go,
oh no,
they just wanted money like.
But there's,
there's a lot.
They all had a lot of money.
When I talk to a big businessman,
now
you know what it is,
man.
It's the deal.
It's all about the deal.
It's all about closing deals,
making deals,
closing deals,
and winning.
That's what it's all about.
It's like,
that's like saying to someone that loves
video games.
Why are you playing video games?
Like why are you playing them?
You've already played.
You played it,
you've got the game.
You know how to play a game.
Why keep playing?
Because they're getting a little juice
out of it.
Every time they do it at the closing
deals or buying a new yacht.
I've got an amazing,
amazing New York,
the biggest shot ever,
so the most wonderful yacht,
the yacht.
You'll see this yacht.
It's amazing.
Wait to you see it.
It's incredible.
The biggest yacht.
That's trump at a nutshell,
right?
I,
yeah.
Do would you want the biggest yacht?
No,
I wouldn't either.
Well,
I know a guy has one.
It's a giant target.
You have to have like have these
military guys at guard this fucking
thing because he'll.
What they'll do is they'll travel this
yacht without him just south of France
and then he flies in private jet of
course flies in to the south of France
and this private jet climbs out and then
they have to escort him to his gigantic
multi hundred million dollar house that
floats in the water and you have to keep
people from getting on your lawn.
Essentially the like the lawn becomes
all the water around your multibillion
dollar house or multimillion dollar
house
and it's just so that you can show your
other billionaire friends like,
look what I got.
Well it's also probably fun as fuck to
take no doubt floating mansion
out there on the south of France,
but I guess it's just why else have the
money?
I mean,
why not?
If you're balling and you enjoy
all that stuff,
like I guess they just want more.
They just keep.
Keep going.
There's something more to it than just
the acquisition of money because once
you have a billion dollars,
you can afford thing all of the things
that you need or can afford.
All those things though.
See One of these mansions,
like if you,
if you look at a mansion like a crazy
fucking Hampton's mansion,
you know,
you could get one of those for like $50
million,
$50 million,
$100,000,000 before taxes,
right?
Taxes,
expenses,
sales tax.
You have to makeup,
you have to earn profit of $100,000,000
to get the $50,000,000 mansion and then
that's not,
that's not shit.
Compared to some of these yachts,
like a yacht can go for half a billion.
Like they have yachts,
like what's the most expensive yet we,
we've covered this before,
wasn't it like a billion?
I think it's a billion.
A billion dollars for a boat.
A billion dollar million dollar boat.
Yeah.
And then what we'll do,
you have to have a jack about how empty
you feel inside when you sit the first
night and your billion dollars.
It depends on how much coke you're
doing.
You might feel totally full full of coke
and hookers.
Yeah,
you probably do.
And you have three phone calls going on
at the same time doing deals and that is
why I 100 percent believe the reports of
that streets of Monaco $1,000,000,000.
That is crazy.
Yeah,
it's,
it's a castle on a boat that floats in
the water.
It's insane.
Yeah.
Well that's a battleship.
That's an aircraft carrier.
Well,
it's really like a city.
I mean,
look how it's designed.
I mean it looked the outside of it.
It all looks like this amazing block and
what this is theoretical,
but they will build for someone if they
give them a billion dollars.
Uh,
let's see.
The difference in a yacht and number
three,
which is a $650,000,000,
it's triple the cost.
What is a billion buying?
You will nothing yet.
This one still in construction.
The design,
that fantastic yacht,
unlike the traditional model.
So this is the probably the most.
It's so it's a replica of a casinos and
the Monaco Grand Prix track.
It's so funny to me that you spend a
billion dollars on something and it
looks that fucking Gadi and disgusting,
like there's nothing about that that
looks cool other than it's billion this.
Yeah,
that's the only.
It looks cool because it's.
It's mimicking Monaco number,
but the number two one is how much that
one,
Jamie,
that's foreign and $50 million to one
point $2 billion and I'm sorry,
anybody with a billion dollar yacht
should be murdered.
I don't think I'm going out on a limb by
saying that they should be killed.
Okay.
It costs a billion dollars.
Maybe we don't know the exact cost of
building such a monstrosity,
but various source of listed the price
of construction.
Even as high as one point 5 billion.
It's manned by 70 crew members and owned
by Russian billionaire.
Roman Abramovich contains its own
private defense system designed to
detect intruders and camera wielding
spectators.
Wow.
It's got a laser to kill to.
We get that.
It uses modern light technology to block
the cameras.
Is Room for 24 to hell.
IPADS and has its own private submarine.
By the time you get the private
submarine money,
something's gone very right and very
wrong in your life,
especially if you're.
If you're a Russian billionaire,
you have to be in bed with Putin.
Oh,
you have to.
Yeah.
You can't just like be.
I'm just politically agnostic.
You,
you'll be straight up drinking a arsenic
at some point or they'll just take your
company and lock you up.
I mean,
they've done that to a bunch of
oligarchs.
He'd just takes your company,
puts you in the pokey.
But I wonder,
um,
do you think that you can be that there
are.
I mean,
I guess like Bill,
Bill Gates and Warren Buffet seemed like
Nice people,
but it seems like if you're a
billionaire,
you're probably like at least a cousin
of evil,
like you've done something terrible.
Is that true though?
I mean,
it's got.
There's gotta be a way to be an ethical
billionaire if there is a way to make a
million dollars ethically,
which we believe there is.
There's gotta be a way to make a
billion.
I mean,
it's just a matter of keeping going,
I guess.
Buffet seems like a good guy,
but then you get into what good guy
means for a billionaire.
Right?
Like good buffets,
good guy is like,
I will allow $800,
million to go to AIDS in Africa,
but I will not allow that same 800
million to go to famine in Somalia.
So there's a kind of a weird moral
arbiter thing that happens which happens
to the president to.
It's like when people point out that
like Obama bombed people with drones.
I,
I'm A.
I was pretty disgusted by a lot of
things Obama did,
but it's like that is part of the
morality of being a world leader is you
have to be comfortable with a morality
that includes killing innocent people.
And that's why I would never want to be
the leader of anything.
Only one reason why there's a ton of
reasons why you'd never want to do that
job.
Yeah.
The worst.
But I,
you know,
there's this idea that people love the
president,
which also like really kind of blows my
mind.
Like why do we,
why do we love our president?
They don't love the president in every
country.
There was a super disturbing video that
a guy no took where he was at the
inauguration and trump is coming up the
stairs and as trauma's coming stairs,
all supporters,
right?
This is,
uh,
you know,
the,
the heart of his love and as he's coming
up the stairs,
people are clapping and applauding and
this guy next to this guy I know who's
holding the camera says,
thank you,
Mr Trump.
You are a godsend.
Thank you sir.
Thank you very much.
And it's,
and he barely acknowledges that guy of
course,
just because it was $100 million people.
Right?
And he wanders up the stairs and goes
through the room and all these people
are following him with the camera on
them.
I think that's what a guy like that once
he wants somebody to say that to him.
Yeah.
He wants to be that guy.
I understand actually being trucked in
that situation and want people to
worship you.
I,
I can get there.
I'm a comedian that's,
that's close enough to a desperate ego
where you like laugh at me is similar to
worship me,
but why do we worship politicians?
I can't wrap my brain around it.
Like Gore Vidal
said that he called it the uniquely
American religion of worshiping the
president.
Well,
I think it goes back to the fact that
we've never had a king,
so our president is a different thing
and I think the idea to have the one
alpha is just some ancient ape shit.
Yeah.
One hundred percent does only makes
sense.
There's always an Alpha champ.
There's an Alpha gorilla and there's
just like these,
these hierarchies exist in the primitive
versions of us.
Why wouldn't they exist in the most
advanced?
That's really interesting.
I never thought about it like that.
Like A,
we're so intelligent that we've created
a stratified Alpha pyramid that is $300
million big with a parliamentary system
and a constitution,
but it's still just a bunch of apes know
running around,
you know,
2001 in.
I mean,
even like,
go back to what we're talking about,
like Bill Gates,
who's this in incredibly,
uh,
what,
what he's done charitably is amazing.
He does a lot of great stuff with his
money mean their foundation is really,
really beneficial to a lot of people,
but everybody knows him as the king ape
of Microsoft.
I mean,
that's how these businesses work.
Tim Cook,
that's the king eight of Apple.
You know,
we always have a king ape or queen ape,
right?
Very rarely a queen a put when we have.
It doesn't seem to work out.
When named Queen Eight that Toronto is
chick was a big queen a,
but it didn't work out because it turns
out she was a fraud.
Who's Toronto's?
You don't want to story.
No.
Oh,
it's amazing.
It's amazing story.
It's a story of something where people
wanted something to be true.
So they kind of said yes.
We finally have and they didn't do any
investigating on it until finally
somebody actually did.
I think it might've been the Wall Street
Journal.
It took it down,
but
I was just woman Elizabeth something or
another.
She,
she founded this company called Toronto.
There she is,
Elizabeth Holmes,
and she dressed like Steve Jobs.
She wore a black turtleneck black stuff.
She acted like she was this super genius
character and when she was 19 she left
college to start this company called
Toronto.
And Toronto is a company that would do
this.
I'm very cheap and effective blood scan,
like they would take a drop of your
blood,
prick your blood and test you for all
sorts of different diseases.
And um,
it turns out it doesn't work at all.
It's just a black box.
No,
but just hugely ineffective.
And she was worth in one point in time
$34 billion dollars because of what this
company was assessed as being valued at
which she could have been able to do.
And um,
it turned out that they started looking
into it and then there was a
whistleblower from the company that was
saying that she was ignoring all the
negatives and concentrate on the
positives.
And these people know untold,
tens of thousands.
And even,
I think maybe even a
million people were put it.
How many people find out how many people
were tested by this shit,
but they were all put at risk because
it's hugely effective,
like off by like 40,
50 percent negatives and positives and
just wasn't right.
It just was wrong all the time.
Does this idea that she was going to
bypass this traditional system and they
were putting them in like walgreens and
stuff like that and allowing people to
get tested and screened for all these
diseases and it really wasn't effective,
but she was one of the very rare king
queen chimps were the matriarchal
society was,
you know,
her business and it didn't work.
You conflating the collapse of the
business to know.
I'm just saying she was the only one
that I can think of.
What would that have been very effective
female world leaders though.
Top,
top chimp,
golden my ear,
Margaret Thatcher.
Merkel what's the woman that got blown
up in some very effective women?
You're like,
what's the one that got blown up?
Who Am I thinking of the,
uh,
who was killed?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
She's a famous goddammit shipper.
Names of the tip of my tongue.
Oh,
early morning podcasts.
Motherfucker day after travel.
Stupid.
What?
What country?
Don't remember.
One of the Middle Eastern ones that they
killed a woman.
Yeah.
I don't remember.
You know what I'm talking about Jamie?
God dammit.
We'll call the line right now if you
know what woman got blown up.
It's a famous story because it happened
in our lifetime.
A Jamie,
you'll find it.
God dammit her.
Her name's at the tip of my tongue.
This is driving me fucking crazy.
Just like blown up like right next to
her limo.
Hmm.
Anyway.
Um,
it's just.
Yeah.
Margaret Thatcher is a good example.
Yes.
But uh,
like companies like lily,
we were talking about like Bill Gates
and stuff like that.
You never see that rent.
Oh,
at the top.
At the top of a Qa.
Carly Fiorina you got.
She was the head of,
uh,
she ran the Republican,
one of the Republican people that ran
for president this and she was at
Hewlett Packard.
I wanted something like that maybe.
Yeah.
What do you think it is?
You really think it's just an ape shit?
Well,
I think there's definitely some women
that have a more masculine
characteristics and enjoy the
competition of the board room and that
kind of stuff more than some women do,
but I think that a day.
Yeah.
Then the country was at Pakistan,
Pakistan,
right.
I was gonna say Pakistan,
but didn't want to fuck it up.
Um,
yeah.
I don't know.
I mean,
what,
what is a masculine characteristics?
What's a feminine characteristics?
Obviously there's massive variations in,
in both genders,
but why are almost all lead?
It's the patriarchy man.
I mean,
it is the patriarchy.
I think it is.
What does that mean though?
What it means is that therapists,
there are systems in place and maybe are
biological systems is what suggesting
it's a primary thing and maybe their
societal systems.
Probably the truth is that they're both.
And I think that a person that really
believes in,
in like feminism and patriarchy would
say the societal systems are more,
are the bigger,
the bigger issue.
Uh,
but even you can believe in the
patriarchy that's biological,
but just that it's more,
there's a barrier to entry that starts
in kindergarten.
It starts in child rearing that would,
that,
that every,
in order for a woman to become a CEO,
they have to have to jump every hoop
higher than the male that want is on the
same path because there are systems or
structural systems in place that want to
snip smack that woman down towards like
a more what is perceived as a no do
something a little bit more feminine.
And so they,
in order to be,
it's this idea that is true with all
oppressed people that in order to be
average you have to be great.
And I,
I saw that directly with like my mother
who's a deaf and uh,
in order I just,
the deaf community is so fascinating and
weird,
but like in order to be what my mother
is,
which is like a,
she has a master's degree and she's
college educated.
You have to try 20 times as hard as an
average person that wants to get a
master's degree because there's so much
insane barrier to entry from day one
from the first day you were born.
So I think that's the patriarchy I don't
think is really up for debate.
I mean even if you believe just in a
biological imperative,
men are in charge and therefore they
keep women from getting to positions of
being in charge.
So in order to get up there,
in order to be a ceo you have to be more
aggressive,
more powerful,
more more Steve Jobs,
you gotta put a put more turtle necks
on.
Well yeah.
But is that,
is that the actual system that's in
place or are there far more men who want
to do that job?
But why would there be more men that
want to do the job?
That's a good question.
Isn't it
natural?
I mean,
is it natural for women to gravitate
towards nursing and physicians and,
and healthcare because that is
overwhelmingly run by women,
but then why are they,
for example,
why aren't they,
why don't they gravitate towards being a
doctor if there is a lot of women do.
Yes.
Yeah,
but,
but doc be being a doctor is largely and
historically dominated by men and there
something that's the case anymore.
It might not be anymore.
You know,
I mean,
I guess what I'm saying is like if you
look at a woman and say,
oh,
well they,
like,
they are biologically predisposed to
nurture,
then you would say,
oh,
okay.
Then it would make sense that all of the
great doctors of history would have been
women or,
or it would have been dominated in the
same way nursing has.
Well not necessarily because a lot of
the great doctors in history,
you're talking a lot about science.
You're talking about the ability to
recognize issues before anyone else does
and try to like formulate some sort of a
solution to figure out some biological
issue.
A lot of that is science and obviously
science has been dominated by men for
the longest time.
The real questions are why.
Right,
right.
And for sure there's been some sexism,
right?
There's,
for sure there's been some oppressing
of,
uh,
women's,
ideas
and their ambitions and entering into
certain fields.
And there's old boys clubs where they
don't want women around because he can't
talk about pussy.
And you can talk about mustaches.
Hitler,
pussies,
you know,
I mean there's a certain amount of
freedom that men enjoy when they were
around only other men and that's in
place because they're the,
they are the Alphas of society.
And so like the freedom that we desire
as men.
And I'm not.
Look,
I'm like uh,
uh.
Woke boy,
I'd like lefty but I still am a man.
Whoa boy.
Well,
you know,
like,
like I consider myself a political
progressive and I do believe in and you
say,
do you ever say I'm so woke?
I mean ironically I will hashtag woke.
Hashtag stay woke all day,
every day.
Hashtag I eat meat,
but that.
No,
that's yours.
Hashtag I eat meat.
You always hashtag things.
I eat meat sometimes.
I don't always.
I think I made it may have.
Well you,
when you have like an what?
Do you have?
Like a seared duck?
Yeah.
I enjoy watching your elk.
Elk.
Instagram.
Thanks man.
Yeah.
Do you eat meat?
I eat meat.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
I eat meat.
It's a weird one,
right?
Neat.
No,
it's a weird.
It's a weird thing like a admitting like
you've got to go
because we know if you're a real
progressive,
if you're real caring person,
it's like,
okay,
you're eating murdered animals.
I mean,
I don't,
I don't think that I am as a,
as ardent a meat eating supporter as you
are,
but I also am not a.
There is a moral imperative not to eat
meat,
right.
I,
I fall somewhere in the middle,
which is.
I mean,
I think every thinking person falls in
the middle,
which is meat probably isn't an
obviously immoral thing to eat because
we want it.
We are,
we are,
we are animals and we want need and if
we didn't,
why does a lie in the meat?
And we shouldn't.
Well,
we're not a carnivore,
but we are an Omnivore,
right?
I,
I believe that,
but there's a lot of people that say
we're not.
That's the big argument.
You know,
I have this weird herbivores.
I will.
Yeah.
It's odd to say the word divorce because
we're not like Mcdonald's.
Mcdonald's,
right?
It's not just that.
I mean,
not that we can get away with eating it,
but their faces designed for it.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
For for a big block.
Actually.
Perfectly.
Have you heard about the new big Mac?
No.
So there's a new hamburger at
Mcdonald's.
It's a big Mac,
but if you don't want all that food,
it's a.
they've taken out one button and one
patty,
so it's just a.
it's a cheeseburger,
but they're calling to the mack Jr.
This is the kind of pernicious.
Real demenTia is a fucking cheeseburger.
So that's what they're calling it.
That's so stupid.
The mac.
There it is.
Jesus.
Come back to you and your solid one less
layer.
So it has the same amount of patties.
Is that to patties?
No,
it's not.
It's one less patty.
One less button.
It's a fucking cheeseburger.
And they're like,
oh no,
no,
no.
But it comes with our special sauce.
Oh,
so it's a bad cheeseburger.
I used to have a joke that actresses are
like big macs.
They never look as good as their
pictures.
It's like,
when's the last time you saw a big back
like that?
Like god damn,
that looks great.
Wait,
what about the third big mac?
The grand mac.
Oh,
they're going,
what's in the grant?
for those that didn't think the big mac
was big enough,
it's a 100 percent beef patties ways.
A third of a pound,
two slices,
one that this is the problem with two
slices of melty,
melty american cheese.
What does that mean?
It's like,
well,
it's not real cheese.
So we call it melty,
melty american cheese.
It's melty american cheese is all one
word.
Melty american cheese.
Stay woke.
Stay melty cheese at all.
Those I eat melty.
I mean it's,
this is the problem with me.
It's not you shooting an elk with a
fucking bow and arrow.
It's mcdonald's.
Like having like,
you know,
couch weights,
stacked up and like they'Re eating their
own shit and we're all like just
consuming it at the detriment of the
global world.
Green greenhouse gases.
I mean,
if only if everybody hunted to the way
you hunt then then there would be no
moral.
There'd be no moral question about elk.
They would starve.
It wouldn't,
we wouldn't make it,
but I will.
We don't.
We don't even need meat.
No,
we don't need it.
That's what I think the weird argument
about veganism from a moralistic
perspective can be.
If you talk about it from an
environmental perspective,
it's very,
very difficult.
I always say like when you talk about,
I don't know if I want to say this on
your podcast,
but when you talk to them about when you
talk about environmental effects of
neat,
it's the same way that it feels the same
as when you bring up the settlements in
Israel,
you can have all these great
intellectual discussions on well
actually,
well,
and then you bring up the environmental
and you just go back.
Can't defend that.
There's no,
there's no defense there.
I feel the Same way with the settlements
in Israel is like,
I can make an impassioned plea for
Israel and then when you bring up the
settlements,
I'm like,
yeah,
I got nothing.
Once you start bulldozing people,
I don't know.
I'm not sure what tanks,
but we started this whole thing off with
trying to figure out why women gravitate
towards certain things and whether or
not there'd be suppressed and this is a
subject.
It's almost like racism where,
uh,
if you're not a black person and you
start talking about black lives matter,
people go,
hey,
fuck head.
Like whaT?
What you,
you either be ultra supportive or shut
the fuck up now you get to be an ally
or,
you know,
get out of the way.
I hear that there is.
Yeah,
I hear that.
And that's kind of representative I
think of the way a lot of women feel
like the struggle is so pervasive and
it's so much a part of their lives and
they don't get supported in it.
And iT's so frustrating,
especially a woman that is trying to
climb the corporate ladder.
Like I have a good friend who's a big
tiMe executive.
She was at google now setting up another
one of those big tech companies and
she's a super,
super intelligent,
super ambitious too.
And she's one of Those rare women that
um,
well her mom's like that too.
So it's kind of interesting,
it's interesting when you meet her mom
who's this older,
super sharp lady,
but she's just always been like the type
of person that enjoys achieving.
She'd like,
this is like her mindset.
She enJoys it.
She likes to achieving problem solving.
She likes getting deals done and she's a
very nice person.
It's not like she's some ruthless
monster who,
uh,
does sit at forsaking all things for
profit.
It's a,
but there's not a lot of women like
that.
It's not,
it's not that many.
So if you look at the great pool of
humans,
like how muCh of it is them being held
back or how much of it is them being
like really rare,
like so.
So few people like that.
If you get 100 women in the room is one
of them,
like my friend,
I don't know.
But the question always is why would
there be so few women that are like
that?
There's no way,
by the way,
it's all an intellectual exercise
because there's no way that you could
strip away all the thousands of years of
programming and systemic societal
oppression to figure out,
oh,
if we're on it,
I always make.
I always think about like if I took 20,
20 kids,
I used to think about this in terms of
gender dysphoria and trans transgender
ideas.
Like if you were to take 50 kidS,
50 boys and 50 girls and go put them on
a colony on the moon where they were
raised by robots with no reference to
their gender.
What things would you find that were
true about the women back home that were
true of the women up there?
Like if you could somehow strip away
society altogether,
then what would be leftover?
What truly is male?
What truly is female?
And I think there's actually a,
there is an intersection between meat
eating and feminine and feminine and
systemic feminism,
which is really like human beings are
this weird concoction of like conscious
aware,
awake woke boys and girls and little
primate,
you know,
kill the alpha.
You know,
fuck the woman.
My monkeys,
and so we're trying to grapple with that
constantly like is it in inherent in the
notion that you should morally not eat
meat is the idea that you are morally
superior to an animal that can't discern
between the moral correctness of eating
meat and you know what I'm saying?
Like if you're just an animal and you're
just like any dog will eat anything you
put in front of it.
There's also,
there's an Intellectual argument,
right?
Like if you leave these animals loan to
their own devices,
what do they do?
Well,
they slaughter each other.
I mean that's what.
That's what they do.
This is what it is,
is a bunch of stuff that grows and
there's a bunch of dumb stuff that eats
the stuff that grows and then as much
stuff that eats the dumb stuff and
that's.
That's nature and that really is the
whole stuff that eats other mean stuff
is mean stuff that he's bigger mean
stuff and smaller mean stuff and then if
you step in and you take some of those
dumb things that are eating the grass,
you can feel better [inaudible] healthy.
Your body performs better and that's
just a fact.
I mean,
there's a lot of people that want to say
that meaning is bad for you.
It is absolutely not.
It's just not.
What's bad for you.
Sedentary lifestyle,
what's bad for you,
his sugar was bad for you is simple
carbohydrates and high quantities.
There's a lot of things that are bad for
your processed foods are bad for your
preservatives are very bad for you.
There's a lot of things,
carcinogens,
all those things are bad for you,
but just meat is protein and water.
I mean that's really what it is,
is a bunch of amino acids and there's a
lot of vitamins in it and as long as
you're not eating too much of anything,
it's been proven that there's a lot of
to eating
meat,
first of all,
be 12,
which really doesn't even exist in a
vegan diet unless you're taking in weird
algaes and or bugs.
Some people were willing to eat bugs.
Bugs are the future,
right?
We're all goiNg to be eating crickets,
but it's a weird thing.
The distinctions of life,
like we decide like for if you wanted to
eat something that's really simple and
stupid,
like if your,
if your issue is awareness or if you're,
your issue is whether it's something
sentient,
eat mollusks.
There are some of the dumbest fuckIng
thing on the planet dumber.
Even then plants,
like plants communicate with each other.
It's been proven.
Michael pollan had some amazing work
about it and not only that,
they have,
not only that,
it's been proven that the communicate
with each other,
but they also produce human
neurotransmitters.
They produce like serotonin,
like there's,
there's some arguments that they,
um,
they actually allocate resources to
support other plants in the community
and talking about those like root
systems or whatever.
Yeah.
They have a micrOrisal relationship with
different funguses.
Some trees where if you go into it,
there's a group of elves make them
cookies.
Yeah,
man,
that's responsible for a lot of forest
fires.
Right?
All those killing cookie up man.
But one of those elves actually made it
really far.
He's actually the attorney general of
our country.
What's happened,
jeff sessIons and now he was an
[inaudible] guy.
Yeah,
one was,
he was,
he was like a top or doping,
but the um,
I think plants talk.
I think it's interesting.
I think they communicate with each other
in a way that we don't understand.
And this is one of the reasons I read,
I think this,
they've done these studies where they
played the sound of caterpillars,
played the sound of caterpillars
munching on leaves next to an acacia
tree and it changed the way the tree
tastes.
Like when,
when you,
there's certain trees that when they,
they,
when an animal's chewing them,
the acacia bushes,
a famous one when an animal's chewing
them up wind.
So like something's chewing it and then
sent comes down wind to them,
they changed their flavor profile and
become a toxic tasting so that animals
will actually starve to death rather
than eat them.
Oh,
they changed so that the caterpillar
won't eat them to discourage predation.
Wow,
thAt's wild.
They do it based on sound,
like they'll do it based on the smell,
but also sound plants respond
defensively.
The sound of caterpillars eating their
leaves.
So they produce these,
these poisons.
So they,
they taste like shit,
but so that no one eats them and it
literally will cause they figured this
out from giraffes,
but that's not evidence of sanctions.
Well,
it's evidence of some sort of
communication because one,
one plant way up there is communicating
with the other plants that are nowhere
near.
That's interesting.
So okay.
So all of the trees and the network will
start tasting like shit just starts.
Interesting.
There's some sort of a network.
Again,
the michael pollan Book,
I forget which book it was,
where he goes into depth about this,
but um,
there's quite a few different,
um,
scientific papers that have been done on
plant intelligent intelligence and it's
a fairly new and emerging field and it's
very disturbing field people that are
vegan because they like to pretend that,
okay,
well we have,
what we're doing is causing no harm.
that's not true.
Okay.
Everyone causes harm.
Life eats life.
And one of the weird things that people
do where they have no problem eating
with their vegan.
I'm just gonna eat vegetables.
Well,
large scale agriculture is one of the
most devastating things that can happen
to the ground that those plants are
planted on you.
You complete,
like if you see a field and it's like a
thousand acres of corn that is so not
normal.
I mean that is just sO weird.
And even if it's totally organic,
right?
Like you're,
you're displacing all this wildlife to,
to do that.
You're changing that environment
entirely.
It's,
you're stripping nutrients from the
soil.
are we like running toward a cliff?
Yeah.
And the way to put the nutrients back is
you're dead.
Things used fish are dead animals and
that's how they get the nutrients back
in the store.
There's a,
there was an interesting article article
that uh,
um,
I tweeted a about a year back that
everybody got so mad that it's actually
impossible to be a vegetarian.
And thIs is by someone who is a vegan
saying this.
What did they,
what,
what are they saying?
You're not adjusting every animal,
every plant like devours living things
in order to stay alive and your
devouring the nutrients from those
living things like by eating these
plants,
you're eating something.
There it is.
It's actually impossible to be a
vegetarians fascinating read because
it's written by a vegan and it's.
It's.
It's a weird argument,
but you realize,
oh,
there's this connection that's
inexorable.
Like it's not like these plants just
live only on water
but isn't the.
I mean,
here's the idea that brings us back to
this feminism idea and what structure on
what is and isn't the idea that if you
are.
If you believe that humanity has a
moral,
it's encumbered upon humanity to be
morally forthright in a more,
to be more than an animal,
then you have to reckon with what's the
way that I can do the least harm in the
world.
I'm not saying I do that.
I'm saying that is,
that's the,
that's the moral and intellectual idea
of like,
you know how to deal with systemic
oppression,
how to deal with a low impact diet.
Like I think like there's no question
that you hunting elk is in the framework
of if I'm god in the acceptibility
range,
right?
[inaudible],
but then factory farMing And you know,
worst Case scenario and worst case
scenario is this is the scenario.
Yeah.
I Think what also would happen is these
societies that we enjoy these
civilizations like New York city,
la,
they got too big before we engineered
them before rather we engineered like
I'm an engineer is the wrong word before
we really managed the resources that you
need to allocate to in order to feed 20,
have 25 million people in the greater
los angeles area.
That's about all that shit.
Yeah.
It's a lot of,
it's so
much shit.
What do you do with the shit?
Do you ever have a story of the ocean?
You ever hear the story about New York
city's shit?
No.
Where's it go?
Pretty fascinating.
So they basically,
uh,
it,
it all goes in the same place.
I mean,
it all goes to plants,
which is a treatment plan.
It's not,
not,
not plants that feel and make themselves
tastes bitter,
but treatment plans.
Right?
So every,
every shitty like,
you know,
lower eastside hipster and chinatown,
chinese person and like upper east side,
you know,
do it all.
There's little squiggly shits.
I'll go into electric plants where they
treat it and then their leftover with
this pile of fucking big old New York
city shit.
And they're like,
what do we do with the shit?
They don't have a farm lands nearby.
And so they basically,
because a lot of it goes to fertilizer,
so they started trying to take it out on
the,
on the free market you can sell shit on
the free market.
Oh my god.
Is that real?
Yeah.
You sell it to farms.
And the funny part is that all these
like Kansas and Indiana and like real
down home corn,
husky type of lasers,
we're like,
we're good.
We don't want that big city city slicker
shit to our community.
Oh my god.
Basically the stigma of New York,
yankee ness was too big for them to
accept the shit.
Wow.
Not even for free.
Yeah.
They wouldn't take the,
take it for free and if they buy cow
shit,
but isn't cow shit way better because
it's all grass will cow shit.
I don't know.
I don't know if it's better.
I'm not,
I'm not a shit expert.
I just dabble in shit.
No,
I dabble in shit,
you know,
so much.
I mean I smelled like it and I think
about it a lot.
But other than that I talk a lot of it.
That's right.
wow,
that's crazy though.
When you think about like how much shit
it has to go somewhere and all the
garbage when you order stuff.
We,
I was getting ready for uh,
for burning man this year and I went to
target to buy pillows and I bought
pillows,
brand new pillows for $4 and I was just
like,
this is great.
And tossed the pillow fresh pillows and
then uh,
my wife was like,
the fact that there are $4 pillows is
systemically connected to societies
collapse on some level.
Like there's no way to make a $4 pillow
and not have the earth like suffering at
some point.
Just how do you do that and all the
garbage and I can go to burning man and
sleep on it for a week and be like,
this is dusty.
Toss it into a landfill.
Where is this stuff going?
Isn't the argument that target pLaces
like tarGet and walmart especially are
subsidized?
oh yeah,
for sure.
Yeah,
they definitely are,
but in one way,
shape or form,
right?
To welfare or through food stamps or
through actually not welfare.
Right?
They have to certain wage to.
You mean to.
Yeah.
In order to support like w how much you
have to qualify for welfare.
Oh,
I think you.
I grew up on welfare.
Actually need to know.
Did you really do you like that about
yourself?
I find a great of pride in this.
Said it.
I just blurted it out.
They're like,
yeah,
me too,
bro.
I do feel like connective.
I get almost nothing makes me more angry
than a person Who's never interacted
with real poor people.
Talking about the lazy people on
welfare.
Right.
Well,
I was very fortunate that my mom,
although we were on welfare,
she worked too and got to a point where
she didn't have to be on welfare anymore
and then she got off.
Same with me.
So it made me realize like,
oh,
like this,
this actually can work,
can help,
same here,
that are super poor.
We had food stamps,
the whole deal and my thing has always
been,
when it comes to welfare,
look,
wouldn't you rather allow a person to
take advantage of the system so that
some percentage of those people can
write,
can raise through the ranks and get off
of welfare and,
and better themselves and better their
lives.
Wouldn't you rather have that system in
place?
Then the system that says,
sorry,
we're worried about people taking
advantage of the systeM so everybody
including the good people can go fuck
themselves.
Which society do you want to live in?
Yes.
There's certainly the former.
And you know,
I think with,
uh,
with my mom's situation,
it was also important to send the
messaGe that it gives a woman an option
to get away from an abusive man.
Yeah.
My mom left,
my dad and My stepdad didn't have any
money and they weren't married at the
time.
They were boyfriend and girlfriend and
he was a student and they,
you know,
we got on welfare and we ate,
we drink powdered milk and the whole
deal,
but it's very similar situation.
Very similar.
My mom left my dad when I was one and
came out here.
She's a disabled wOman.
It's like everything was stacked against
her and uh,
you know,
so we were raised on food stamps and
welfare jews on welfare.
Very rare.
It's,
it,
it definitely.
If you have a society that's a caring
society,
it's,
it certainly serves its function.
What people are worried about is the
same thing you're worried about when
they're talking about free housing.
I was just gonna say we can bring it all
the way back.
Yeah.
You're worried about people that come
along that juke the system that don't
want to work,
that are lazy.
who cares?
Yeah.
Let them.
Duke wouldn't you?
I mean,
I just,
I would rather help people that need the
help and allow someone to juke the
system than I would live in a stark
society that says,
I'm sorry we don't help people here
because we're worried that somebody
might steal 100 percent and you know,
there's a real issue that's coming up
right now with artificial intelligence
and automation that's gonna remove
millions and millions of jobs just by
virtue of automated cars are done.
And so people were talking very
seriously about universal basic income
is either inevitable.
There are two inevitabilities,
either universal basic income will come
and take the place of the income that
was stripped away,
not because anybody did anything wrong,
but because they did everything right
and the eventual automated reality is
that there aren't jobs from people.
There's job for you and me,
but there's not a job for a skilled
journeymen worker because there's a
fucking machine that can work 24 hours a
truck driver.
Oh yeah.
A truck drivers are there first.
They're the shock troops.
That's why this whole thing with trump
saving coal jobs,
it's like,
I hate to say it,
but like coal jobs
don't matter,
you know,
and in the long,
and I know it's like,
it's like this hollywood,
like comedian juggler look cool jobs
don't matter and I know if you're a coal
miner listening to this,
the coal job matters to you more than
anything else,
right?
You know how Few coal jobs are.
It's very few,
very few.
There's like $75,000 overall coal jobs
and there's some insane like new energy,
like there's a half a million new energy
jobs just in California alone.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And so everybody kind of made those
numbers up,
but it's big and everybody paid.
Everybody focuses on the human being.
Does every,
they focus on the,
on the day to day,
they focus on the sun going up and down.
They don't focus on the year going by,
right?
It's like you go,
oh,
but my job is gone.
I want my job back.
But it's like your job doesn't matter.
Yeah.
entire coal industry employs fewer
people.
That arby's,
holy shit.
Imagine if he was talking about arby's
though,
but I think what he's doing is sort of
like this giant pro business push
transparent.
It's so transparent.
It's,
it's obvious.
It's just about Making a lot of people
that he knows money and allowing a bunch
of people that have lost money that have
probably in some way or shape or form
contributed to him.
Yeah.
And also he's not an idiot.
I mean it might be,
but he also won the election by about
the amount of people that work for me.
It's
definitely not an idiot.
She's probably got some kind of high iq
that is overshadowed by a severe
personality disorder.
Yeah.
And what do you think that is?
Like narcissistic.
Yeah.
I just think he's.
There's something wrong with him.
No doubt about that.
For sure.
There's something wrong with them.
Don't you think that in order for
someone to put their name up on
everything like that.
Like I was in New York this past weekend
and we drove by this like trump
research,
a rehabilitation center,
trump rehabilitation center.
It was like this real shitty old
building.
Yeah.
What they do is they put a,
they put a,
a crack rock in front of you and it,
and they say,
which one do you want to grab?
Just keep diverting you do the pussy.
And then further down the line it was
trump links were driving on this road
and it said trump links golf course.
So it was golf.
I know about the trunks.
Trump steaks,
steaks.
Like,
oh,
have you never seen this commercial?
It's really funny.
The trumps state commercial is like,
oh,
you just gotta you gotta love it.
It's so beautiful.
Really.
You can you.
Can you play video on here?
uh,
is it illegal or something?
I think we'll put it for us.
Yeah,
we'll play the volume that whenever we
play a video,
the real issue with us,
it seems to be,
um,
animal attack videos because those get
so many hits that somebody owns them and
claims them.
And then you get pulled off of facebook.
I got off of youtube,
we get flagged.
Trump steaks is like hilarious.
I mean,
look,
trump's not a fool.
Trump is a,
well,
he is a fool,
but he's not stupid.
And the trump steaks,
the world's greatest days.
Give me some volume young jamie.
When it comes to great steak,
it just raised the stakes at the sharper
image is one of my favorite stores with
fantastic products of all kinds.
That's why I'm thrilled they agree with
me.
Trump steaks of the world's greatest
stakes,
and I mean that in every sense of the
word.
And the sharper image is the only store
where you can buy them.
My are by far the best tasting,
most flavorful beef you've ever had,
truly in a league of their own trump
steaks or fivestar gourmet quality that
belong in a very,
very select category of restaurant and
our certified angus beef prime.
There's nothing better than that of all
of the beef produced in America.
Less than one percent qualifies for that
category.
It's the best of the best until now.
You can only enjoy steaks of this
quality in one of my resort restaurants
where america's finest steakhouses,
but now that's changed today through the
shop image.
You cAn enjoy the world's greatest
stakes in your own home with family,
friends,
anytime trump steaks or rage to
perfection.
Provide the ultimate and tenderness and
flavor.
He
absolutely loved trump steaks.
Treat yourself to the very,
very best life has to offer and as a
gift,
trump steaks are the best you can give
one bite and you'll know exactly what
I'm talking about and believe me,
I understand steaks.
My favorite food and these are the best
because it was kind of endearing when
she was just a businessman.
So call that wacky businessman guy.
Here he is.
It's the trump guy.
It's like there's a guy in India,
they used to dress all in cold.
I know the guy you're talking about.
It's kind of something funny about it.
He's a character.
What's the trump guy?
Puts his name on everything and but then
he become president in that.
What made you kind of cute?
Is it terrifying with?
Yeah,
I mean that's the president state guys
talking about sticks in the exact same
way that he's talking about governmental
policy.
how the fuck,
the sharper image they sell back
massagers oh,
they sell them the best steaks in the
world.
If there's no place,
I would rather get my meat and then the
sharper image I go to brookstone or
sharper image.
That's my butcher donnelly that whoever
wrote that,
like that's in need of a second draft,
so is a terrible why it's so good.
I would eat.
I would push back and say,
donald trump's not a big second draft
guy.
He's just like,
uh,
I'm going to say I'm really good and
know a lot about it and let's do this.
He's right up there with l ron hubbard.
When it comes to second drafts,
did you
you watch the choice on frontline during
the election?
No.
It was this amazing documentary about
hillary clinton and Donald Trump and it
shows you exactly who they are and why
they are the way that they are.
Hillary clinton,
who cares at this point,
but trump is so interesting.
Like basically he was raised with a
father that was extremely harsh,
not loving it all,
and he found this father figure,
this guy ray cohn,
who was this like an extremely
aggressive lawyer in new,
who was
a big in the mccarthy erA.
He was a prosecutor in the mccarthy
communism trials and cones.
Whole strategy and philosophy was when
someone hits you,
you hit them back on a level that's so
disproportionately out of control that
they forget about the thing that you are
even talking about.
so the example of,
uh,
how he got sued for racial
discrimination is getting sued for
racial discrimination.
That's a bad thing.
Remember that.
And he sued the people that Were suing
him for $25,000,000 in 1970.
So it's like now the story is,
oh,
a $25,000,000 suit,
donald trump's suing some poor kid for
$25 million.
No one's talking about the original
thing anymore.
They're only looking at this flashy,
insane pt barnum level lawsuit.
The racial discrimination thing was in
regards to housing,
right?
Yeah.
That basIcally there was a,
they were setting up the systems where
black people and latinos wouldn't get,
wouldn't be allowed into trump housing
through like weird coded language or
something like that.
Well,
he's definitely a very litigious guy.
Oh yeah.
which is fascinating that this woman who
is suing him for sexual harassing or
groping or what is she?
What is exact?
It's a gloria allred thing.
Oh,
I don't know the suit that you're
talking about,
are they still going?
No,
this is the thing.
He just claimed immunity because he's
the president.
Like this woman was suing him before she
was one of the ones that sued him once
he became president or once he was
running,
she came out like one of the last few to
came out and gloria allred was behind
her and everybody was,
oh,
see this coming,
let's gloria allred's in your corner.
You're like,
oh,
I See what's going on here.
So I'm just trying to get paid.
But okay.
Someone's trying to get paid jump claims
immunity from apprentice contestants
lawsuit that somebody's trying to get
paid.
That's a fair.
I could see that argument.
The other argument would be he's about
to become the president,
so a person who he's violated who was
willing to let it go when he was just
some weird guy selling steaks for the
sharper image is now like,
I'm not gonna let this monster become
the president.
Well,
you could look at it that way.
Um,
but what is,
what did he do?
Like he did,
but her claim that she's been pretty
open about our clamp.
He made a passenger.
Yeah.
that's really it.
YeAh.
So it's not,
it's not really like what it can
constitutes.
It's not,
you're not talking about something
monstrous.
No,
I'm not talking about it.
But in this case,
the gloria allred thing,
like,
um,
you know,
gloria read like I was a woman and uh,
something was going down like that where
I wanted to get paid.
That's who I'd go to.
Like that's her thing.
She,
there was some,
some article written about how many
cases of hers actually go to trial and
how many get settled and it's just,
she's a settlement person.
You ever been sued now you,
yeah.
Clothes.
What about,
uh,
a lIne in my book and uh,
and it is,
you realize immediately that it was a
stupid line and one that if I had,
had,
had hindsight,
I just never would have put it in and
the person right to be upset and uh,
but then you realize very quickly that
this is poker,
we're just playing poker,
like it costs so much money for you to
go to trial and defend yourself if you,
even if you felt like you did nothing
wrong,
which in this cAse,
you know,
I probably wouldn't have even made that
claim.
I mean,
the thing about writing a memoir is it's
all like these wisps of memory,
you know,
and you're just like grabbing stuff and
throwing it in and like you have to.
It's almost like you have to write the
first one in order to realize like,
oh,
here are the responsible ways to do
this.
You can't just like grab memories
thinking that all of your memories
belong to you because other people are
in them.
You know what I'm saying?
So anyway,
basically it's like if you could defend
yourself,
maybe you have a defense will cost you
$200,000 or you could settle.
That's what I no longer buy this idea
that like if you settled,
that's an implication of guilt.
That's,
that's coMplete bullshit.
Anybody thAt's been sued is realizing
the reality that like you could fight
for your honor and it'll cost you double
the amount for you to just say here's
some money,
but I know a bunch of people that have
been sued and settled when they were
absolutely 100 percent innocent and they
actually passed a rule at the ufc.
Were you not allowed to take pictures
choking people because of it?
Because people would ask,
okay,
chuck liddell come choke me.
Take a picture.
You put me in a rear naked choke hold.
Both chocolate dell and matt hugheS were
sued.
Chocolate dell wound up settling and he
absolutely didn't do anything wrong,
but this guy had a picture of him
getting choked and he says,
look,
this guy hurt me.
He'S a killer.
You hurt me.
Here's the picture.
Oh,
pretty cut and dry here.
And the other one was mad.
He was the same thing.
This guy wanted matt.
He was choking him so mad he was choked
him and this guy wound up suing them.
Then they do an investigation on the guy
and like they go into it and they find
out that this guy is a corrupt cop.
So the guy winds up going to jail for
being a corrupt cop.
Hilarious.
He started this whole cascade that
eventually wound up with him being in
jail.
Yeah,
I mean people are.
LiTigiousness is,
is,
is a monster of our age.
But it works.
Yeah,
it works really well.
I mean a company that I'm part of,
I got sued recently,
some weird funky patent lawsuit and
like,
oh,
what do we do here?
And it was one of those things where
you,
if you settle you,
you get this amount,
you know,
you give them this amount.
If you go to trial,
it's going to cost you in legal fees
three times that even if you win,
what's chocolate l supposed to do it.
Okay.
Chuck,
you could,
you could defend yourself and maybe when
you could spend $250,000 and maybe when
even though you're right,
or you could write this check for
$20,000 and never think about it again.
It's like I get that.
What's weird about trump being so
litigious is that the republicans were
the ones that made it almost impossible
to sue people.
That's their whole thing.
Do you saw that hot coffee documentary?
Yes.
So fucking good.
Right?
And that was a republican talking point.
It's like we have to start with tort
reform,
tort reform,
and then all of a sudden there were all
these like,
you know,
meaningless and frivolous lawsuits.
That's a bIg talking point in the glp
and all of a sudden now trump is like
the most suing this mother fucker that's
ever,
ever touched anything.
Would you hear him talk about it during
the,
during the,
uh,
run for president?
He was talking about
people writing things about you that
aren't true,
and we're going to change the laws.
We're going to change the law so we can
go after those people.
it's harvey firestone or trump.
They're doing right now.
Uh,
that was trump.
no,
I was not good now.
Hover fire thing that maybe that was too
deep of a cut.
I was trying to.
I don't know.
Nobody wanted that would be more like,
here you go.
I just don't know.
A good trump says I can't make that
speaks to your spirit.
Does it?
That you can't find that.
Do Mike Tyson?
You're good at tyson.
I don't do it.
I'm pretty good.
Oh,
that's difficult.
I got,
I got stephen hawking and I got the
movie phone guy.
Those are the two.
That's it.
That's how I got.
Welcome to a movie phone.
People don't even know what movie phone
isn't you?
I know.
There's no point that.
Yeah.
What about one of my impressions is
defunct.
Goes up.
Hello and welcome to movie phone brought
to you by one.
Oh,
six point one.
and kmel jams.
If you know the name of the movie you'd
like to see.
Press one now.
Yeah.
They used to be the thing.
That's where the movies are played and
what the times were.
Phones used to be so connected to the
Internet.
You ever studied hacking?
You know,
it's like all of the original hackers
like these,
like really like phone.
Yeah,
the phone freaks do what they were doing
was like not even interesting anyMore.
Like captain crunch,
you know about that guy.
He's an interesting dude.
I knew that dude really when I was a
little boy explain who he is.
Oh,
so captain crunch is one of the first
phone freak hackers and the thing that
he did is he found a whistle and a
captain crunch box and he found that it
had the tonality that if you play it
into the phone,
like whatever the tones that the phone
was hearing were similar to the dial
tones that would connect people to long
distance so he could get free long
distance.
Now kids,
this is when long distance cost money.
So he was one of the first dudes that
was doing that.
He's a legend.
So I met him when I was a big raver when
I was a kid.
I was Like big time.
Like I spent most of my teenage years in
san francisco raves and so I started
going to have 16 and captain crunch was
like 70 and he was at every rave,
I mean every single rave.
And he was 70.
He was old and it was funny because.
And he was just doing ecstasy and
partying big time.
No teeth in front of the speakers,
like speaker freak like you now.
He was a phone freak,
then it became a speaker free.
So he's blown his ears out,
just like sitting there full of fear,
like no teeth,
little shorts.
And I was like 16.
And who he is,
there he is.
Yeah,
he said to me,
uh,
it looks very good.
Guy does a lot of ecstasy.
oh yeah,
he's done it all.
So that dude was like,
do you want to,
do you need a job to me because I was a
cute young young boy.
You want to fuck anything?
I don't know if you wanted to fuck me.
I've been sued before so I have no
opinion on that.
But I do know that.
He said,
I do know that he.
I was like,
hell yeah,
I want a job,
and he's like,
great.
It starts with a body work session that
my house in mill valley and I was like,
eh,
I'm good.
I'm good crunch.
Who has to deliver the bodywork?
He's the guy.
I mean,
basically it starts with a body work
session.
You ever had a job like that?
You meet a metal rake.
Jobs.
There are 70 year old man.
You made it a rave.
They do a bodywork.
No,
that's legit.
What are you going on about how weird?
That was a hard pass.
Hard pass.
How many people said yes to that?
I guess that's one of those pitches,
you know?
Yeah,
we'll try it enough time.
Throw it at 100 people and every now and
then it's like,
oh,
I'm sure he's thinking a baseball
metaphor.
Yeah.
I wonder.
That's how weird fucking choice.
I was very interesting to me.
Thank god.
I was like aware enough that it was very
transparent.
Maybe if he'd,
you know,
when you're young,
sometimes things that are very
transparent or not transparent at all
you like,
oh,
okay.
I guess I'll do that.
no,
I almost got a.
When I was maybe seven or eight,
probably eight.
I almost got scooped up by a child
molester because of that.
I almost did to what happened with you
don't want to hear yours.
I was in a library.
I used to like a monster books.
I was really into monsters,
like dracula,
guys like,
hey kid,
you like monster.
Why was
he,
um,
I was looking through this section,
this horror section of this library.
And um,
this guy came up to me and he said to
you,
you do you like books about monsters?
Just said,
yeah,
yeah.
He goes,
I've got some really good ones in my
car.
Do you want to see them?
And I was like,
okay.
I was like eight.
I was a total latchkey kid.
My parents just opened the door just
out.
Why went?
They worked when you get home from
school and you basically were at the
mercy of society and I lived in san
francisco.
So it's like from,
I was born in New Jersey and we moved to
san francisco when I was seven.
Serious thing.
We have a lot of parallels.
interesting.
I'm from oakland,
you know that.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I.
Same thing.
I was in a parking lot,
accident my car in the car and my
grandma went in to go shopping with my
brother and this dude came to the window
and was like,
do you want to come with me?
I'll give you a bicycle and thank god
I'm jewish.
Because I was like,
okay,
I'll take the bicycle,
but I don't actually ride a bike.
I need training wheels.
And actually my brother needs a bike
too.
He liked,
I swear to god.
I started negotiating with the guy.
I was like trying to get more bicycle
for my box.
And then by the time I was done talking
to the guy,
my grandma came out and was like,
chased the guy away.
So if it wasn't for these negotiation
skills,
that's amazing.
I'd be in a sex dungeon.
Right?
No,
you were annoying.
You had the guy away from me.
Now that's hilarious.
even a child molester,
he was like,
I,
you know what,
forget it.
Yeah,
you can keep it.
I was on my way out the door with this
guy and the lady who worked the counter
at the library or the librarian screamed
at joseph,
you get away from that man.
He just got out of jail.
Jesus and the guy ran.
He ran and I started crying and just
crying and crying.
The joe rogan experience could have been
so different.
I mean,
the Guy just got out of jail.
He probably did want to go back to jail
again.
Do those little things,
minutes and seconds between you and the
most dastardly thing.
I mean,
not only that,
this is 1970,
whatever.
It was like,
good luck catching that guy like,
yeah.
Have you ever almost died?
I don't think so.
What's the most dangerous thing you've
ever done?
Oh,
jesus.
I don't know.
Fight the fight and die and a drive safe
or drive unsafe.
Yeah.
I remember I was a kid and we were
always like,
look,
exploring places to go smoke weed.
That was like when you're young,
I,
and maybe it's different now,
now that weed's legal,
but when you're young and we,
it was illegal,
it was like you always were like looking
for these cubbies,
just smoke weed.
And so you'll appreciate this as a bay
area guy.
The,
uh,
somebody found this a chain link area
that you could get over and get onto
the,
uh,
the bart tracks where you would go.
I've been in the bar tracks before
because I was a graffiti writer when I
was a kid and so we would sneak down
there,
but this was like a very narrow liquid,
just a foot long walkway and we end.
Somebody said that there was like a room
inside of the tunnel that was between
oakland and contra costa county,
that there was this little,
I don't know how they knew that,
but like a little anti chamber.
We were always like looking for anti
chambers to like,
there was another one that was like a
sewer tunnel in oakland in rockridge
that I could show somebody where it is
right now,
but it's basically you go down and we
would bring flashlights and hairspray
and lighter so that we could like torch
spiders if we saw there was a little
anti chamber there too and there was an
anti chamber,
like a little know a room inside of a
tunnel,
like a,
like a.
I don't know what,
why it was there,
but there was like this little sewer
room in there that this guy fro hawk
lived in and there was,
he was like a black punk rocker.
He lived there.
He did.
He had,
he lived on the lawn on a lawn of like a
pool folding chair down there.
He slept.
I slept there one night actually.
But anyway,
so we were always just,
you not relate to that,
like you're always like looking at you
and your friends,
like looking for a weird place to do ill
explore.
Yeah,
exactly what to do that kinship.
Yeah.
So we were in there and I was like,
I was kind of chubby when I was a kid,
so they made me go with the back.
It was like a one person,
you know,
walkway to get to the room in the middle
of the tunnel,
not the sewer tunnel,
but now the bart train tunnel and we're
on this little one foot walkway.
And um,
I was aT the back of the line and we're
walking towards the room and of course
we will get into the tunnel and we could
feel all of a sudden like the air got
hot and sucked out of the tunnel and it
was like,
oh.
And you could hear that level of like
bbb,
bbb beep and the train was coming and it
was like,
it was so close to us.
I can't,
my memory,
I don't know if my memory is accurate,
but my memory is that it was like,
I mean,
this as close as this mic is to me,
just like food,
food.
And we were all like up against the
wall.
And then the funny part was that we all
stopped and then the train stopped.
I remember they pulled the,
like the train stopped in the tunnel and
they must have maybe they saw us or
something and somehow it stopped.
I
don't know,
maybe that's not an accurate memory,
but I feel like yes,
the train stopped and I,
I know that the people at the front of
the line screamed,
turn around and like run,
but now all of a sudden fat moshe,
young,
fat moshe wiifm is at the front of the
line.
Right.
And it's like a strip stand by me
situation because I'm like chubby,
like,
and there's all this wind coming at me
because the wind is all been pushed by
the train.
So I'm like trying to run from the train
conductor and they're screaming all my
friends like run,
run,
run you fat motherfucker.
The worst,
scariest,
craziest experiences.
And then the train finally pulled off
and the we'd like hopped back over and
like shaking.
We'd like smoked weed in the just in
public are like,
fuck it,
we don't need to go a caverns.
Me and a buddy of mine in high school
hopped on the back of the tea in boston,
you know,
the um,
public transport.
It's a train essentially.
It stopped and we jumped onto the tracks
and climbed onto the back and wrote it.
The train served on the back.
I've done that.
Not on the train,
but on the,
the uh,
the buses,
the ac transit buses.
There was a trick where you could grab
the,
there used to be like a handle on the
back of the bus and you put your feet on
the bumper and right,
like basically write it like you were
like a illegal immigrant or something
and we would just do that for fun from
one if you want to take like one stop or
whatever.
It was so scary.
It was so stupid.
It's like the risk of like falling off
of that thing was so dumb.
You were on top of it?
No,
we were on the back.
Oh,
just holding on just like,
oh yeah,
it's so crazy.
Like standing on something and holding
onto something.
But it wasn't a good grip.
It wasn't,
you know.
And if there was anything that really
bumped you,
not that it would on a train,
but if it did,
most likely I wouldn't let go.
I mean,
it was fun though.
Being young was very fun.
Stupid.
Being stupid was fun.
It's just amazing.
When you think about how many times
things like that happened,
you go,
oh yeah,
there was that time like you asked me,
did I do anything dangerous?
Like,
oh,
let me think.
And you have to go over these things.
Yeah,
I did a lot of stupid shit.
A lot of climbing things you shouldn't
have climbed.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
We'd start a fire once in a warehouse.
I remember once we found this chemical
in a,
uh,
in a way somebody broke into a car and
found all this chemical.
I don't know what it was,
but it was some like volatile flammable
chemical.
And there was this cement slide at the
elementary school in the neighborhood
that we lived in.
And so we poured the chemical down the
slide and lit it on fire.
Just not familiar with the concept of
explosives,
but it was,
there was a wall of flame,
I don't know what it was,
but it was so big that we were,
I think we were on acid and,
and,
and we were in the after this big old
wall of sliding flame,
like,
like the cut.
We were chilling out in this place,
the grassy field up above there and the
cops came and they were like,
we've heard reports that there's someone
playing with a flame thrower.
I remember we laughed so much at peace
ops because like,
anyway,
now that was a good memory.
Well we were a lighting bottle rockets
in this field and I'm one of the bottle
rockets ignited some grass and I stomped
on some of the grass but then some,
it started out real small,
like a laptop size fire,
you know,
stomped on it,
but it just kept going.
It was going left and right.
And then you try to circle around,
but then the side of it gets bigger and
then you can't catch it.
And then it got to the point where like,
oh fuck,
I can't do this.
I can't,
I can't stop this out,
and then it's whoosh,
and then it became a fire and we were
like 13 and we ran and we got to the
street right when we got to the street.
Just dumb luck.
Aqap was there,
we just gave it up right away.
We started firing and the cop was like,
get the fuck outta here.
And we ran and we ran and then the
firetruck came and then we assessed it.
The next day we went by.
We didn't go anywhere near it.
We were just hoping and praying.
Like to this day,
my parents don't know I did it,
but hoping and praying that nobody died
and that,
you know,
we didn't go to jail so we didn't tell
anybody about it.
Then we went the next day and it was
just,
it's massive surface area of fire.
Everything was black.
This enormous field,
like several football fields sized.
Obviously it's number 13.
I,
uh,
I remember that we were once out in,
we were all on mushrooms.
I don't remember this.
this is all when I'm like 13,
by the way.
Jesus christ,
that's the problem.
That's why I got sober,
so yeah.
You're a bad example though.
For someone who uses drugs as well.
If you do drugs and fucks your brain up
because look,
you're very smart.
DId it.
Did a lot of acid.
A lot of mushrooms.
Yeah.
I loved it.
I did.
we talked about it last time I was here
at how much I fondly remember I'm
psychedelics anyway.
But you,
you're sober because of other things.
No.
You know,
in reality,
I think we talked about this last time,
but in reality it's like now that I look
back,
you know,
especially writing that book,
the book covers all of this stuff,
all these wayward youth stories,
all these insane.
It's called catcher in the rye in case
anybody wants it.
I'm very proud of it,
but it's like once I wrote that book I
realized like I was a wild kid just like
you,
you know,
or,
or maybe wilder than when you were
really young,
but I was a wild kid with a lot of
behavioral issues,
a lot of mental health stuff going on.
Not like,
not like chronic and systemic,
but like circumstantial and I spent a
lot of time thinking of myself as like
an alcoholic and I don't knoW what,
what if I even believe that,
that I didn't even know if I believe in
that label any longer.
But you don't believe in the label.
Well,
I just talk about this afterwards.
I mean basically I don't know is
basically it has nothing to do.
People always want to ask you that.
I go,
oh,
I got sober.
I was 15,
and they go,
oh,
cool.
Crazy.
What were you doing?
And it's like,
then the answer is always very
embarrassing.
So nothing asset,
pot drinking and now I realize like it's
not really embarrassing
because the only reason it's
embarrassing is because I've been like,
I want to say heroin.
So the people will go,
oh,
I acknowledged that.
That's legitimate,
but I didn't have that story.
That's Not the truth.
The truth is really the question is why
did it should be,
why did you get sober?
And the answer probably would be because
I was a juvenile delinquent and that was
the way out that I found at the time.
And I probably could take mushrooms now
and before,
but I don't know,
you know.
That's interesting.
That's really interesting.
So do you ever think about exploring it?
Definitely.
Yeah.
I Think we did talk about this stuff.
But definitely I do.
But what,
what keeps you from doing that is,
is it this distinction that you have
where you're,
you're a sober person for sure.
There's that membrane.
I think about that a lot.
It's like membrane.
You're either,
you're like,
like you are either you are or you are
not.
Right.
And that's part of it.
Part of it is a,
a,
you know,
a harm reductIon,
best practices type of thing.
It's like everything's good.
You know,
I know a lot of drug addicts,
I know a lot of people that use drugs
and have great experiences.
Right.
But I know a lot of people that got
sober and thought,
oh,
I'll try again,
and then they're all fucked up.
right.
I don't necessarily think that would be
me,
but I do know that,
right?
Uh,
and one a and finally I just,
yeah,
I guess I worry about like,
just habituated,
but I mean,
it hasn't affected you.
It seems to have affected you in the
opposite way.
Yeah.
You're,
you're better.
But everybody's different.
Everybody is different.
And what I,
I'm not doing coke doing meth.
There's no argument for meth or coke
maybe even see.
I mean there's no argument from math
period that just doesn't.
It doesn't.
There's not going to expand your mind.
Although I guess there's an argument for
adderall.
Yeah.
Because you want to sit down to write a
script over a weekend.
There is an argument to be made for.
That might be a bullshit script about
cleaning
script,
about organizing your underwear based on
color.
Uh,
drugs are weird,
man.
I mean,
I'm a big drug advocate.
Big time.
I'm not,
I'm,
I,
I think that they're powerful and
unnecessary and I want,
I want psychedelic experiences.
I've had them,
but I had them.
I always say like the funny part about
taking mind expanding drugs when you're
12 years old is that there's very little
mind upon which to expand,
you know,
you're like doing these things that are
like rom das,
ask like deep diving into the fractal
pool of existential reality and there's
nothing there.
You're just like point it.
So it's a weird experience.
Like you're having these freakouts and
you know,
your mind is bursting open,
but uh,
I certainly wish I would like the
experience of trying that with an adult
brain.
Maybe It'd be worse maybe,
but I doubt it.
I don't know.
I mean,
I think that what would drugs do,
what any drug does is it alters your
brain chemistry,
right?
And everybody's brain chemistry is
different.
So some people could use a cup of
coffee,
right?
And some people it freaks them out and
some people
could use some pot and some people just.
There's a lot of people that I know that
they just go into deep paranoid fits if
they get involved with marijuana in any
way,
shape or form.
Right.
Whereas I kind of liked that self
exploratory and examination aspect of it
because I think,
I think it's far too easy to be cocky as
far too easy to not be introspective or
that paranoid feeling.
I think it just,
it forces your brain to examine all
these perhaps uncomfortable truths.
So you're saying you'd like the paranoia
aspect of it?
I think it's beneficial.
That's really interesting.
I've never heard that before.
I think it's beneficial because I think
what you're paranoid of when you're
paranoid the.
Unless you're thinking the government
spying on you and I'm like,
I know a buddy who was a big time
pothead and he started thinking that
the,
that the government was waiting outside
of his house with a car and they were
watching them constantly.
Everywhere he went and as soon as he
left they would come out of the bushes,
like he got a little crazy,
but I think he had his own issues.
Yeah.
And he was also dealing with.
His dad was dying and it was a lot lot
going on,
but that's one of the weird parts of
drugs is that.
And I don't think that I have this,
you obviously don't,
but one of the weird things about drugs,
if you have latent mental illness and
you get into your brain and you pour a
chemical on it,
it'll,
it'll unlock itself,
you know,
get the dragon will uncoil and make
itself known.
I don't think that.
I'm not worried about that for me,
but I think that is interesting.
I've seen that a lot.
Like a dude's like 25 and it's like,
oh,
I think I'll try start trying
psychedelics or weed and it just goes in
there and it's like,
oh,
you didn't know you had that.
Not that they wouldn't have had that
experience anyway,
but it's definitely a,
a incidental onset of mental illness.
Yeah.
There was a study they did about the
correlation between marijuana and
schizophrenia because a lot of people
have tried to connect marijuana,
schizophrenia.
And what they found is essentially the
numbers are stable.
It's one percent,
it's one percent across the board.
So it's one percent that whether they're
doing pot or not doing pot.
And so you can make that correlation.
Like this guy got into pot and look at
all these examples of people who started
smoking pot and became schizophrenic,
but that's just humans.
Yeah.
There's a certain percentage of people
that just will become mentally ill.
That's a scary.
That's the scariest thing.
I have a brother who has schizophrenia
and it's like the scariest thing ever.
Regular kid rig,
totally regular sweet person.
And then all of a sudden one day It was
like,
are you okay?
And then couple of years later it's
like,
oh,
you're,
you are done.
Your brain is cooked and what is,
what is,
what happens?
Well,
uh,
he was in New York so I didn't see the
entire uncoiling but it's basically,
you know,
he starts weird and gets weirder and
then at a certain point you're like,
oh,
you're different.
You're a different human being.
Like you just giggling to himself,
smirking weird outbursts,
just scary,
scary stuff.
And it's like your brain turns on you
and there's no.
I mean it happened around when my dad
died.
So I sometimes I think to myself like,
oh,
maybe that was it.
Maybe in the same way you pour weed on
it,
maybe if you pour,
you pour trauma on it because trauma's a
brain chemistry buster to 100 percent
and so I think
that probably like popped the scab open
or whatever that was in his brain,
but yeah,
a year later was lIke,
oh,
you're a different person.
You don't have the same personality.
You don't.
It's,
it just shows you how much of you is
just brain chemistry and how lucky you
are in the same way.
You were lucky not to get,
you know,
kidnapped by a monster at the library.
You're also lucky that the monster
wasn't living inside your brain.
Yeah,
me too.
Well,
there's,
there's all sorts of dIfferent kinds of
mental illnesses,
you know,
I'm sure I've got a few right.
Like whether or not they're beneficial.
That's the other thing.
I of the,
I was talking to michael irvin once the
football player and he was describing to
me what happens to someone's brain when
they're in the womb,
when the mother experiences violence,
uh,
the mother experiences any sort of
violence or really bad neighborhoods or
around traumatic situations that it,
it elevates the,
uh,
fight or flight response in the baby.
So kids come out of the womb,
like pre predetermined to overreact to
violent situations are dangerous
situations.
I definitely think I have that.
That's interesting.
I can,
I ramp up way too quick.
I calm myself and I'm,
I'm very aware of it.
So I,
I,
I control it and I'm,
I know what it is,
but like if something goes on,
like I,
I hit red line,
like immediately laura goes from zero to
100 miles an hour in like a second.
And that's not usually manageable.
Right?
I mean that maybe that's a link to our
earlier conversation about the
patriarchy.
I mean,
if you can pass on incidental trauma to
a child because the mom is experiencing
violence.
If a woman is living in the,
you know,
infrastructural like 20 700,000 layers
deep of infrastructural oppression,
then it stands to figure that a female
child is born with a little bit of that
trauma too,
and a little bit of dna based like,
um,
maybe I won't fight that fight or maybe
I won't be pushy or maybe I won't be
allowed broad or maybe I won't,
you know,
argue because that's not feminine or you
know what I'm saying?
And so all of that in,
you know,
trauma,
intergenerational trauma,
which has been studied and proven,
right,
is maybe is maybe in every woman that
you've ever met.
Oh,
no doubt about it.
I mean,
I think all of us have some form of
programming.
I mean,
if you ever been around a kid who has an
overly oppressive dad,
you know,
and they're,
they're,
they're handicapped by it.
You know,
literally,
like whether it's a boy or a girl,
that their life is affected by this
overbearing person who's constantly
engaging in manipulation and control of
their reality.
That's what you get when you,
you ever had a.
I'm sure you've had a friend.
This is a drug addict.
The most tempting thought in the world
when you have a friend that's a drug
addict is just like,
why don't you just stop,
just stop doing that.
Stop it.
It seems so stoppable cause it's so
selfish and so like obviously the wrong
thing to do and you're over here doing
the right thing and such with such ease
and what having my brother's mental
illness,
my,
my younger brother,
it made me realize is like you actually
have the same thought when there's a
mentally ill person.
It's just with the,
the next reality is like,
oh,
he really can't.
It makes everything clearer,
right?
Like sickness,
cancer,
you don't say to the person stop because
you're just like,
oh you can't mental illness.
You say stop,
but then you realize you can't drug
addiction,
which is like kind of a mental illness.
You say stop and it seems seductive to
believe that they could stop and if you
could really be compassionate and say,
oh,
he can't.
That's like,
you know,
that's like compassionate nirvana.
Yeah.
And you can take it to another place
too.
With gambling,
it's really the same thing.
So an emulation of human human
neurochemistry,
like somehow or another,
a betting money on things gives you that
charge that you cannot.
You can't escape the grip of it.
Like there's a lot of people that are
really,
really addicted to gambling.
I've seen it.
It's crazy.
Which is really crazy that the
government has fucking legalized
gambling everywhere at gas stations.
Those goddamn scratch tickets are
nothing more than legalized gambling.
Lottery legalized gambling.
Are you.
And you're not anti-gambling though.
I mean,
I'm for it.
I'm not,
by the way I want it.
Yeah.
I don't do it a lot,
but like before I worked for the ufc,
I used to bet on fights all the time.
Oh really?
You don't have the.
You don't have the bug,
the bug?
No.
I used to enjoy betting on pool to play
pool a lot and I would gamble on pool
games,
but it just made it more thrilling.
I never got addicted to it.
But you do,
you run the risk,
you run the risk of getting caught up in
it,
maybe to a lesser extent than someone
who has an issue.
People seem to have inherent issues with
it.
It's like it gets you filipino woo.
They love playing pool and gambling.
Yeah,
I shouldn't.
What the filipino.
Okay.
Thank you jo.
Because now it's time for me to bring up
my grand race theory.
Okay.
The fIlipinos,
filipinos are some of the best pool
players in the world.
Is that right?
Yeah.
And it all happened in a,
after the war,
a gis went to the Philippines and they
introduced pool.
Interesting.
and uh,
you know,
it doesn't cost a lot or you need as a
table.
There's a lot of outdoor tables in
manila and a lot of the islands,
there's thousands of islands.
I don't know if you've ever been.
No,
I never been there.
I know how it does,
it seems like a,
a contiguous country and it just so
isn't like culturally too,
like from one to the next,
like they like muslim extremists here
and like catholics here by the way,
they are like weird people too or that I
get like,
you know,
I'm kind of in the muck of the internet
sometimes,
you know,
and I'm kinda like trying to shake up
some of these uh,
uh,
outright trees,
you know?
What do you mean?
I don't know.
I just like getting into it,
you know,
how do you get into it?
I like,
you know,
I post and then people shit post me and
that kind of like go back and post,
you know,
the posters.
We had explained shit posting to me,
oh yeah,
shit.
Posting with people,
let's posting,
you know,
these
are the people that they,
they think of themselves as the people
that named trump into the white house
right there.
They're kind of like,
they're almost like a,
the people that think that the right is
the new punk rock.
That's who they are.
They're like,
they're down to like get in and they
think that the disruption of society is
inherently good,
so they or they don't care and they just
want to fuck shit up so they,
you know,
they'll,
they're the people that like when I get
an antisemitic post lobbed at me with
like a big old nose and like,
uh,
hey jew or shut them down like the,
I can't express to you how like water
off my back that,
like,
it couldn't bother me less,
you know what I mean?
Like,
because I just know that it's probably
like an asian kid or like,
you know,
a black kid.
It's like,
it's not even actual antisemitism.
It's like a computer person going let's
just fuck with some.
Like this is the,
this is the attack.
Like if you were going to play chess,
rook to king,
whatever,
you know,
it's less thought out than that.
It's just messy and chaotic and what's
the most offensive in most insane,
you know,
most wild crazy attack that I can make.
And so,
uh,
there,
there's a philosophy,
it's a weird kind of anarchistic
philosophy to it.
And it started in four,
chan and kind of,
you know,
it bubbled out to uh,
uh,
to uh,
anonymous is an outcropping of the
fortune.
I wouldn't call them shit posters
because they have like at least kind of
a cogent philosophy,
you know.
But,
uh,
anyway,
the shit posters are the people that
when you tweet something sincere about
how angry you are about trump,
all of a sudden you see like 90 cartoons
of the most offensive thing that you
could possibly imagine.
You're like,
why did these people,
why are they attacking me?
And it's because they like looking for
people.
Little whiny bitches.
Like,
you know,
they're like,
oh,
we found a little tiny bits come this
way.
And then all of a sudden it's just a
tidal wave of these things.
Well,
if you call them,
if you say their name,
that's where it gets really strange.
So she wears done exactly what she's.
I looked at some posts that she made
recently about some magazine cover that
she was on,
showed up on my feet.
And then I read the comments.
It was like,
jesus christ.
Yeah,
she,
if she was a ship,
it would be so filled with rats.
You'd have to light a fire,
right?
It's,
yeah,
it is like rats and barnacles too
because it's just like all of a sudden
they're just like two,
two,
two.
Yeah.
But barnacles could be on a cool ship
and you get in there and there's a lot
of people drinking and have a good time
and barnacles on the outside.
This is rats beCause it's everywhere.
It's in the pantry.
It's in every aspect of it.
It is,
it is a part of the new landscape and
where we live,
this digital landscape is filled with.
I mean in a way.
I mean I don't,
I don't like them.
Obviously they're not nice but.
and I think decency is,
is a sad,
a collateral damage of the digital age,
you know,
it's just like everybody's in decent
now.
Somehow people Think that being in
decent as positive and that if somebody
disagrees with you politically,
like it's fun and okay to just try to
destroy that person emotionally.
Well you're not really communicating
with them in,
in front of you.
Yeah,
exactly that that is a huge aspect of
being a person is looking at someone
while you communicate with that,
removed that there's consequences to
that.
Well,
yeah,
everything,
the pr,
a big problem is the other end and the d
and the internet has made othering so
simple and easy,
you know,
it's like the arcgis was watching this
documentary and they were talking about,
it was this really good documentary
actually about,
I forget the name of it,
but it was about this guy who he's a
black dude that confronts kkk members
like one on one,
you know,
and he like talks to them and to them he
converts them and he's like,
he's d hooded like 24 clansman or
whatever.
And there was a story or hooded them as
It were.
What were,
what hood there.
There's actually an a very intense.
Have you seen the documentary?
No,
I haven't,
but I've heard of it super intense
moment in the film because the whole
time you're with a guy so charismatic
and brilliant and interesting and you're
like,
wow,
this guy's,
this guy's righteous.
Can you look it up?
Sorry,
I can find it.
what's his name?
He's really fascinating.
Jamiel what's the moment?
so there's a moment in the documentary
where you're,
you're the whole time you're in there
going like,
this guy's righteous and awesome.
It's cool.
And d hooding these people.
And then he goes and speaks with these
black lives matter activists who are.
Oh yeah,
accidental courtesy.
That's right.
Daryl davis and race in America.
And uh,
he's interesting.
But then he goes and he talks to these
black lives matter activists and they're
so angry with him there.
So not into what he's doing because
they're basically like,
we were In the streets fighting for
black America and here you are spending
your entire life talking to these
racists and you've only,
you've only d hooded 24 of them.
But it's also.
So there's,
there's a point that they're making.
I was like,
what are you even doing?
What's even the point of what you're
doing?
But his point is I'm making micro
victories and I'm converting people one
person at a time.
But there's a bigger conversation which
is really interesting.
Which is that the person that is closest
to you ideologically is more offensive
to you when they don't do what you want
them to.
Then the person that's furthest away.
In other words,
when a person calls me ju online,
some dude in the Philippines with like
an anime avatar and he puts like
antisemitic stuff.
I give a fuck about that.
That's not real.
That's not real to me.
But when a person who lIke seems like
they should get it,
who seems like they should know that
better says some weird antisemitic shit
or talks about like,
you know how cushner is connected.
Like the global zionism is like,
that's when it bothers me more.
Does that make sense?
yeah.
No it does.
It does.
Because you think they should know
better and they're ruining the cost
because they're connected to your idea.
Exactly.
So at any rate,
there's a story in there where he talks
about a talking to this person who's
like a.
He lived in an all white town except one
of the klansmen that was d hood.
It talks about he lived in this all
white town and he was raised very racist
and that black people were the worst and
there was one black family like the
johnson's or whatever,
and his father told him,
all black people are the worst of the
monkeys.
They're the worst except the johnsons.
The johnsons are good.
They're good people.
And he had thIs realization,
this tickle in his brain of like,
wait,
my father hates all the black people
except the black family that he's met.
like all black people are bad except the
one group that he's actually met.
And that is like the phenomenon of
othering,
right?
It's like,
oh,
black people are bad.
Muslims are bad.
But actually my friend tom,
the muslim,
he's nice but muslims wanna kill me.
But the tom over here,
he's a good dude.
Hmm.
Anyway,
I think othering is like the big one of
the big problems that we have.
Well,
it's also,
I think what's going on with black lives
matter.
One of the things that's going on is
that they're in the middle of the battle
right in the middle of the battle.
Everyday.
YOu wake up prime for battle getting
online,
you're active,
you're,
you're activating your membership,
you know,
organizing,
doing whatever.
and then this guy comes along and he's
doing something totally different.
He's out there talking to the klansmen.
You'll fuck those people,
man.
Doing right.
Totally.
Yeah.
I was for my show that,
uh,
that I'm doing my comedy central show.
We're doing like we just did a cultural
appropriation episode and I was
studying,
so I was studying.
I was like deep in the cultural
appropriation of the reading.
So much shit about it.
But one of the more interesting things
that said about black lives matter,
it's kind of connected to this is that
one thing that happens with cultural
appropriation and things in general is
that people seize on language.
We're in like a crazy language war right
now,
right?
Like so many of the phrases that we use,
uh,
are so charged with secondary and
tertiary,
meaning that we can't,
they don't even mean anything anymore.
Like white privilege is a concept that
the moment you bring it up,
there's so many I levels of eye roll
that it's like,
I don't even think it's a useful phrase
anymore because it's like the moment you
say white privilege than a person,
the white person who you're saying it's
privileged just going like fuck you,
and the minute someone saying fuck you,
your conversation has ended.
So the thIng they said about black lives
matter was also a lot of silly.
People use that expression.
No doubt.
That's the weird baggage that it has.
Like it's good.
The thing that we learned about that I
learned about cultural appropriation
because for me,
I.
I roll my eyes so deeply.
The concept of cultural appropriation,
right?
It's like,
oh,
so I shouldn't eat burritos anymore.
Is that what you're also.
I always think I'm always really tickled
with the idea of like the person saying,
oh,
you shouldn't wear that tribal gear,
and then it's like go to the third world
country where the market is and tell
them like impoverished a merchant like,
oh,
I'm sorry I can't buy this bit of silk
from you because it's racist for me to
wear it.
That person's like,
please,
please buy it and wear it.
Like,
or you know what I'm saying?
Or like the family that's like,
oh,
it would be a great honor if you would,
where the sorry or whatever.
So it's a big eye-roll except then you
start to think like upon reading it it's
like,
oh,
the thing is it's not incidental,
it's emotional.
It's like deeper than,
than just like trying to parse out the
logic and go,
oh well I found an example where your
thing falls apart.
It's like it's emotional.
There's an emotional reaction.
Like when,
when somebody you know affects,
you know,
dreads up their hair even though you can
say,
but people have been dreading their hair
in other cultures for a million years.
Vikings had dreads and that is true.
It doesn't matter because the person
that's in front of you,
that's a black person that's going,
I have pain when I'm.
I have this pain that I'm looking at,
you know,
a person that's affecting my culture
without any of the negative parts.
Right,
so you can,
you can wear the hair and you can have
the.
why is that okay?
Just because of the word culture,
because if that's the case with someone
else,
some someone else wearing something that
you might find a failure.
What if you're a person that's extremely
a conservative when it comes to dress
and you see a woman in a short skirt and
you have pain,
should that impose upon that woman's
ability to wear that skirt?
No,
definitely,
and I'm not making a case that anybody's
pain ought to be automatically adopted
as like a behavioral standard.
Right?
That's not really.
What I,
I learned from this whole discussion is
it's like it's not really about going.
No one is really saying except the most
emotionally kind of a inferior,
like the person that doesn't have the
language to express what they're really
saying.
Almost no one that I read when I was
reading these real like intellectuals
and their concepts of cultural
appropriation is saying white people
should stop doing this stuff altogether.
Almost no one.
I didn't find one left wing woke article
that said white people should stop
adopting the culture of other,
of people of color.
Right?
I read a lot of right wing think pieces
that were saying this is absurd.
Why are you telling us to stop adopting
these cultures?
Isn't all culture a melting pot and all
cultural borrowing,
but not once did I read somebody's
saying white people stopped this
altogether,
but what did you read?
so,
so mostly,
and I hope I can articulate this well
because I'm not the best advocate for
this position because like I said,
it's,
it's one that I struggle with that's
dubious,
dubious and difficult.
And,
and there are ridiculous parts of the
cultural appropriation argument,
but one thing that like,
it's all connected to historical trauma.
It's all deeper.
Like basically,
let's see if I can articulate this well,
what this one,
um,
this one person,
and I wish I could find his name
actually,
but uh,
because he deserves it because he's a
really deep thinker about this stuff was
talking about was that,
you know,
we have racism.
Racism is a,
a huge word that describes everything
from a white person like hugging their
purse closer to their chest when a black
person walks by or even like a weird,
like,
you know,
just the smallest little racial
weirdness all the way to lighting across
on somebody on somebody's lawn to
murdering someone.
LIke that's all encompassed and racism.
So they started trying to like parse it
out.
People are going,
oh,
when you call someone a racist,
right?
They go,
I'm not a racist.
You're calling me a monster.
And then somebody will go,
oh no,
I meant like a systemically racist.
It's like you need more specific
examples.
So cultural appropriation is one,
white privilege is another.
There's all these,
but still go back to what,
what cultural appropriation.
Like you said that no one was saying
don't do it.
Right.
So what.
So what are they doing when they're
trying to chop someone's dreads off?
Okay.
I don't know about the spa.
A spa.
I mean,
what,
what example?
You mean the san francisco state example
where the girl attacked guy.
I mean that girl was just inarticulately
expressing some insanity.
I don't,
I don't think that's defensible.
And I,
and I think most of the articles in the
stuff that I read about that specific
instance or just like basically saying
that women's,
uh,
an uh,
a lunatic.
Well,
I've heard people though enforce it and
I know someone who was mad at their
friend is a black girls matter.
Her friend who was a white girl who had
braids,
she had like cornrows and she was mad
because she was saying that it's
cultural appropriate cultural
appropriation.
I said,
do you know about bo?
Derek?
But like she was one of the first people
to ever have cornrows on roman coins
actually.
Right.
I mean it's,
it's crazy thing to call that cultural
appropriation,
but also saying that a white person
shouldn't wear that.
That's fucking crazy because what do
you.
What about a black guy wearing a polo
shirt?
Well,
okay,
so,
okay.
There was a good example is a,
and again,
I'm not like,
I'm not the greatest advocate for this
position.
I just read so much that made me
empathize with the position.
Not necessarily agree with it,
but empathize with where it's coming
from.
So the polo for example,
when you see you as a white dude or me
as a white dude,
when I see somebody wearing a polo,
it's just a polo.
It has no historical antecedent,
it has no historical baggage to it and
there's no connection to systemic racism
or,
or elvis presley stealing the cream of
the intellectual musical crop and then
never giving back to that community or
iggy azalea coming in,
adopting a black accent and then just
like taking all the money and running,
you know,
it has no connection to deeper root
systems like these trees have the
communicate with each other,
like taste bitter,
right?
So all it is is a polo.
It's just a guy wearing a polo and
that's why the the counterargument
doesn't make sense because it's like
nobody's upset when they see a black
dude and a polo shirt.
I mean maybe some weird racist guy is
his,
but mostly not.
On the other hand,
when a person sees a,
like a,
a white person affecting a deep part of
black culture without any of the baggage
that is associated with it.
Like for example,
dreads,
right?
One of the arguments I read a lot is
that like white people wearing braids
and dreads,
you know,
you get rewarded for it,
you look cool,
you look awesome and meanwhile black
women are having a difficult time
getting a job because they have black
hair or black people getting fired from
jobs because they have dreads.
Right?
So there's these consequences that black
people experience because of black shit
that white people that are adopting it
don't necessarily experience think
that's true at all.
I,
if you were working in
an office and some white dude at dreads,
he'd be highly suspicious of his
behavior.
Well,
for example,
like is this guy's kind of like a dork?
I hear what you're saying.
I'm going to hire him.
There's a guy that had hair like you and
right next to him with some stinky white
dude with them.
Stinky dreads has dreads.
Stink.
Okay.
Take dreads out.
Let's say that's a good example.
Would there in the us military,
there was just a,
a new,
um,
a new set of acceptable hairstyles and
mo,
almost every one of the unacceptable
hairstyles that they,
that they accept,
that they put into place.
It was basically black hair,
like braids,
wearing your hair natural.
I don't know the actuaL.
What do you mean?
I mean,
I would have to,
we'd have to be like an afro.
Yeah.
Short afro.
I mean,
you're not allowed to do that.
You'd have to pull up the article to
give these specific examples.
But basically there are a million
different examples like that.
And like I said,
I'm not,
I'm not necessarily an advocate for heat
and,
and honor the call of the appropriation
accuser.
I'm more like now realizing that,
uh,
I'm more now realizing that there's like
just a lot of deep emotional,
weird trauma underneath every,
every accusation of appropriation.
It's not that I think therefore white
girls shouldn't wear braids.
It's that I think I understand more
where the person that is upset is coming
from it.
Just from a compassion perspective.
You know,
I get that.
It just logically,
it doesn't jive.
It's not about logic.
Yeah,
but it should be all human interaction
should have some basis in logic.
If you're going to communicate with
things.
I don't agree because emotions aren't
about logic,
right?
But should anybody be subject to your
oWn emotions like should like,
you change your behavior,
your dress.
If you're a person who's completely not
racist but you enjoy the way your hair
looks and braids should you take into
consideration all the people that you're
going to run into and they're going to
be upset at you over braids,
even though they're ignorant about the
history of braids and carneros,
should you alter or change your
behavior?
Should you accept the fact that you're
just going to have a certain amount of
cultural appropriation?
Well,
let me ask you this.
Like if you.
I don't have an answer to that question.
I don't think so.
That is an important part of this.
I mean,
if you're going to accept the fact
there's some sort of an emotional
attachment to these things and that's
where the argument comes from.
Shouldn't you decide or at least
contemplate whether or not that emotion
is valid?
It doesn't seem to be.
Seems to me there's real examples of
racism and horrible things.
Like if you want to,
you know,
make your eyes squinty and look like a
japanese character from a bugs bunny
cartoon in,
you know,
1940 and then you want to go to a party
and people think you're a racist.
You should,
you should be aware that you're
presenting an image that is inherently
racist.
Like,
that's,
that's something that's kind of fucked
up and you should be considered about
the way people's emotions are going to
fire up looking at your image.
That's what I'm saying.
Yeah,
but that's a different thing than
braids.
Oh,
but oh,
but that's what I'm.
I'm not advocating.
First of all,
I'm not advocating anything.
I'm just saying I've done.
I've delved into this topic enough that
I started to understand where people are
coming from when they,
when they get activated by this stuff
too,
but I think a big part of it is
reinforcement in the community that
that's acceptable to be upset at people
for corn rows or brave and I don't.
I actually don't disagree with you.
I think you're right about that and yet
I think it also is connected to like a,
a legitimate emotional reality that's
happening.
Like for example,
by the way,
the logic is,
is very important and I would say logic
is more important than emotion when it
comes to communication,
but it doesn't because something is more
important,
doesn't negate the,
the importance of the other thing.
well,
it certainly doesn't solve the situation
just by clearly using the logic.
You mIght get a certain percentage of
the people that agree with you because
of logic,
but that's more rare than it is common,
right?
It's like,
would you.
Would You feel comfortable going to a
native american powwow,
you know,
with a headdress on,
not even a power.
There's a powwow next door.
You can see It and you're at a music
festival.
Would you were an indian headdress?
I wouldn't,
but the reason why you can't and the
reason why you shouldn't or the reason
why it's an issue is because the people
are marginalized.
Let me tAke my own people.
I'm italian and my people,
for the longest time there was a lot of
anti italian races.
My grandfather talked to me about it,
what it was like coming off the boat,
but then somewhere along the line it
became acceptable for italians in,
in american culture where it's not.
There's no real racism.
It doesn't stick and cause a Guinea to
our face.
We will laugh.
No one cares.
You could make meatballs and spaghetti
all day long.
Nobody gives a shit.
Nobody accuses you of,
uh,
you know,
you have a pizza party.
Nobody thinks it's cultural
appropriation,
but try having a taco party,
try having taco tuesdays people get
pissed to you.
Why?
Because mexicans still experienced real
racism in this country.
Whereas italians largely just don't,
right.
and like taco tuesdays and example of
something that's like,
who fucking cares,
that's not important.
And,
and so if I'm wearing a sombrero,
exactly offensive to people,
If that's as,
that's as deep as most people go,
that's dumb.
What are you talking about?
A kennedy to taco.
I mean that's done and it is dumb,
but if you kinda like get under the dme,
which is the name of my,
my third,
my third special.
So it's mouth.
It's live,
live in oakland now.
fucking hitler and then get under the
dme.
But if you get under the first,
like the most,
the epidermal layer of like flashy
insanity and go like,
what's really happening here is like,
oh,
it's just what you're saying actually
you're more woke than you than you let
on june interest.
It's like it's really about power
dynamics.
Is that really about the appropriation
incident?
Although on some level maybe it is.
It's really about the power dynamic
underneath it.
Well,
I think one of the things that we're
seeing in universities in particular is
people that are exercising the ability
to affect change.
Even if it doesn't make sense,
they have the ability to,
uh,
point out something that they think is
incorrect or is unjust and then they
attack it and go after it and then they
see and by seeing
those results,
it's almost in a lot of ways kind of
attached to the same idea.
Like if you're worth x amount of
dollars,
why do you still chase money?
Because you're trying to get the thrill
of the accomplishment.
There's the game that's going on and
there's a certain amount of game going
on trying to get that white kid that you
don't even know to cut off his dreads.
Whether or not you know that the romans
wore dreads,
whether or not,
you know,
the greeks wore dreads,
the vikings and all these different
people have them.
It doesn't matter.
It's like there's a little tiny white
guy and that girl could yell at that
white guy then chase him with a pair of
scissors.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's,
it's the incidence are the absurdity.
But the,
but the current,
the conceptual current is somewhat
valid.
I mean,
to you,
I'm sorry,
you know,
to some degree,
like even you and I think that you're
naturally skeptical towards concepts
like cultural appropriation because,
and I am too because as,
especially as comedians,
it's very easy to see the absurdity and
it's stupid and it's so,
it's so pointless.
Like what?
We can't not adopt each other's cultures
that won't ever happen.
So,
but even we go,
okay,
but I wouldn't wear a sombrero to a
mexican club.
I wouldn't walk into a club like,
oh,
hey,
what's up?
Right.
So,
so if you say,
okay,
it's almost pornography,
right?
I know it when I see it.
I know when I know it's offensive when I
feel it.
Right.
You know?
So if you kind of expand further and go,
okay,
even the absurd examples,
I kind of understood,
I'm going to try to understand for me,
I'm going to try to understand where
people are coming from with that.
Then I can kind of contextualize it now.
I don't have to agree with it,
but I can at least say,
oh,
I get where this is coming from.
It's coming from historical antecedents
of racism and oppression that are
connected to hairstyle and,
and the,
and,
uh,
all of these musicians that have taken
black culture and made money off of it.
There's all this like deeper sedimentary
layers of emotionality.
I don't have to heat it and change
accordingly,
but I do.
I would be foolish to ignore it.
Right?
Yeah,
that completely makes sense.
And also I get it from a point of view
of a person who comes from a culture
that used to be maligned and isn't
anymore.
So
I'm from a culture that used to be
maligned and then I thought wasn't
anymore.
And then very recently things have
gotten weird again.
It's really easy to say that jews are
responsible for a large problem.
Part of the problem in the world today.
I've seen it a lot lately.
It used to be like reAlly inappropriate
thinking and talking just 20 years ago
ago,
it used to be very taboo and it is not
anymore.
And uh,
it's uh,
it's,
it's weird.
It's very weird.
It's definitely,
I,
you know,
I don't take stuff antisemitism.
Antisemitism is like the closest I come
to believing in magic because it's like,
it's like I'm not a big mystical guy,
but like antisemitism has never gone
away.
It just has an eye.
I could see if you're an anti semite
you're going.
The evil of the jews is the closest I
come to believing in magic because they
just never stopped being evil.
Like I just don't understand how this
never goes away.
It never goes away.
It's so fucking weird.
Like no matter where jews have lived,
no matter how assimilated they've been,
you know that the jews in berlin where
the most assimilated jews in history,
they,
they didn't.
They were known for having christmas
trees and eating pork and that they
would describe these christmas parties
were only be jews because the germans
wouldn't go,
but it would be all of them worshiping.
I mean a celebrated christmas.
They were the most assimilated jews
ever.
And that was the epicenter of the nazi
movement.
Yeah.
So it follows the jews and I mean,
I know that,
I'm sure at least one of your listeners
is like,
no,
the jews follow it,
but it's like,
it's crazy.
it just won't go away.
It's a,
it's a,
it's a virus that won't ever ever die
down.
Well,
I think there's,
there's a bunch of problems with this
antisemitic thing going on.
Um,
and one of them is the accomplishments
of the jews are very disproportionate,
especially european jews.
If you look at european jews and nobel
prize winners,
it's fucking staggering saying jews who
were intellectuals,
chess champions,
a bunch of,
there is a select gene pool,
especially particularly european jews.
Nobody talks about it that I don't think
that's true.
No,
true.
I thought it was a no.
Okay.
Giant people.
So everyone's probably a huge hogs.
Um,
but do you know the story of fritz
haber?
Fritz harbor's one of the most shocking
a jewish stories in terms of a,
a,
a jewish scientist who was a part of
world war one on the side of the
germans.
He aLso invented the hopper method of
extracting nitrogen from the
environment.
You know,
nitrogen Is one of the most important
things when it comes to fertilizer.
We were talking about fertilizer plans
and nitrogen is 80 percent of the air we
breathe.
Most people think the air is oxygen and
carbon dioxide.
It's mostly nitrogen.
And then there's some oxygen and then
there's some carbon dioxide we breathe
out that that plants use.
Fritz harbor figured out a way to
extract nitrogen from the acts of the
actual oxygen from the actual air around
us and take that nitrogen and use it in
the soil as fertilizer.
And he won a nobel prize for that.
And 50 percent of the nitrogen in most
people's bodies came from the harbor
method like his.
This is like from,
you know,
the early 19 hundreds of sky figured
this out.
It's still being used today.
He also was the first guy to invent
using poison gas and they use it on the
allied troops in world war one.
So he was wanted for crimes against
humanity and simultaneously winning the
nobel prize during world war one.
And then when the nazis took over,
he,
um,
he created zyklon,
a client a is a,
um,
it's,
it's a gas that has a very distinct
smell and I think it was a pesticide and
they used a,
the smell was added to it to make people
acutely aware that this pesticide was
being used because it was very poisonous
they changed it to be,
which is they use the gas,
the jews.
So this fucking guy created the actual
gas that was used in the fucking
concentration camps to kill the jews and
they just took the smell out of it.
That's how they created zyklon b,
whatever that thing was,
they added to icon a to make it smell
bad.
They took that out for his icon based.
So it was almost odorless and they were
killing people left and right with it.
And he was forced out of the country.
I mean,
it's a crazy,
crazy story.
I mean,
when he was going to,
um,
the front line to help implement his
gas,
uh,
on,
on the allied troops,
his wife shot herself in front of him
and he left his kid behind with his
dying wife to go to war.
it's fucking crazy stories.
Crazy.
And he wound up dying seeking refuge
away from Germany.
He was one of the few scientists that
they didn't want a few jews.
They didn't lock up and he just couldn't
tolerate.
I mean he couldn't stand by while these
other jews that he knew were going to
the concentration camps and people were
being rounded up and he'd go leaving.
Did he know that cycle b?
Yeah.
I think that might have happened.
Like while he was,
while he was on the run.
Not sure I'd have to get into that,
but I mean that would be a crazy
realization that,
I mean it's like the,
you know,
the t and t guy.
I either built dynamite,
like realizing what he'd done to the
world.
I mean,
how about oppenheimer,
right?
Yeah.
I mean oppenheimer is quoting the
bhagavad gita.
We played that on the podcast last week.
Come the death destroyer of worlds.
Fuck man.
Speaking of billionaires,
being able,
I mean,
to have that quote is like that's a big
yikes moment.
Yeah.
So I mean,
I think there's.
That is that jews have been so almost
genetically smart for so long.
There's a reason for that.
You know,
what is it?
Well,
it's that basically in the whole of the
dark ages,
the dark ages are characterized by
people being illiterate.
That's they were in the dark and only
the clergy could read that.
The jews were a 98 percent literate
people and that is literally the reason
if you want to talk,
it actually comes all the way back to
systemic oppression.
Right?
In the same way that there are barriers,
you know,
if you're deaf or if you're black or if
you're a woman,
there are barriers you have to jump past
if you are given an advantage.
I mean,
it's all evolution,
right?
Then you're going to leap forward,
and so when you have a history of 500
years where no one in europe reads,
except for the jews and the clergy,
well,
no shit,
they ended up,
you know,
being at the front lines of,
uh,
of nobel prize winning and science and
intellectual ism,
not because they're obviously,
but because they just were reading that
whole time.
And there'S a reason for the idea of
jewish greek too,
is that,
you know,
about this is,
is that,
you know,
jesus said somethinG about usury.
Basically,
catholics were not okay with a lending
money at interest,
at an interest rate that was against the
rules,
right?
And,
uh,
so you're not going to lend people money
for no interest.
That's just not how it works.
And then there were some people that
weren't subject to the rules of
christian anti usury laws and those were
the jews.
And so the jews would lend you money at
an interest rate.
But who do you hate more than anybody on
earth?
Who is the person you wish you were
dead?
Your creditor.
You're the banker that is going to
foreclose on your home and is going to.
Now I'm not saying that's good or bad.
I also hate the banker,
but that's just historically speaking,
when they called jews moneylenders,
it's not because jews are like,
oh,
I'm pernicious and I want to fill this
gap.
It's that nobody else in society would
lend people money.
And so not only were they the creditors
that people hate it,
but they were also the financier's that
made the possibility of european,
you know,
greatness occur because without capital,
without funds,
you can't build a society.
So,
uh,
that is one of the many reasons that
people have come to hate the jews,
is that they lent them the money and
that they needed.
And then when it was time to come
collecting,
they'd be like,
fuck this dude.
So fascinating.
We could find the root of certain
prejudices.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
for sure.
That's a good one.
Those,
those two are very good ones.
Especially the one about being literate.
I mean,
absolutely.
That makes sense.
I mean that it wasn't until I was like
the 14 hundreds with martin luther that
they distorted translating the bible
into a phonetic alphabet where people
could read it and means stop and think
about that.
It's crazy.
It is what happened with martin luther,
the reformation and the printing press
with martin luther is the was the
cracking of the old guard of of society
and finally made demo democratization of
knowledge available to everybody and you
know that everybody was at a
disadvantage of historical disadvantage
and the same thing as you can see that
truth in other systems.
That's a system of oppression to.
Yeah,
sure.
That's a systemic oppression where the
clergy wanted to keep information from
the people so that they could keep them
stupid and keep them under foot.
Yeah,
and those people.
There was a patriarchy there too,
except that the patriarch was god or
papa the pope.
It was really the clergy more than it
was god.
God wasn't really enforcing these laws,
but the literal patriarch pope.
That was one of the most problematic
things about martin luther apparently
was that he was telling people,
you're allowed to interpret what this
means.
You don't have to accept anybody else's
interpretation because they're just men
as well.
Right?
Those are just human beings
interpretation,
interpreting the word of god,
so if you interpret it to be a different
thing,
you're allowed to do that.
And they were like,
what in the fuck is this saying?
Yeah,
I mean think about how seductive that
must've been for the church.
Like,
oh,
we can just keep the information from
everybody and just tell them anything we
want.
We'll bAck then also the.
The pope had women.
The pope was allowed to fuck all the
clergy.
Fuck they were rockstars.
They weren't what we think of now as
these creepy dudes molest children,
right?
No,
they were fucking.
There were.
These were people that had armies.
I mean they called upon the pope when
gang is con was conquering,
like going over the steps and conquering
Russia.
They were calling upon the pope and
though the army of rome,
I mean that's literally where he had
power.
It's very strange when you look at how
that's changed and now it's become this
weird cabal of odd older gay men,
you think,
what do you think of that's about by the
way,
thank you.
Take people's ability to have sex away
and the only people that are going to
stay are the people that are creepy and
sexually repressed and there's a few
that hang in there and they say,
well,
you know,
maybe I can just go without sex and they
get weirded out and then sex becomes
this horrible taboo thing and of course
when sex becomes a horrible taboo thing,
then people gravitate towards sex.
She'd take the ability of people to have
sex away from people.
They want to have sex more than they
want anything in life,
right?
It's like a or or is the opposite?
True?
Is it that people are.
Predators are attracted to a system that
is shrouded in privacy and no sex and
they can,
you know,
they can.
I gueSs the question is like,
do you go in there trying to be holy or
trying to get away from your sexuality
that then bursts out in this abberant
way or are you an absolute monster that
goes into the clergy to prey on people,
but once it's been established,
maybe both,
that becomes part of the issue because
when you're,
you're also indoctrinating young
children that do get molested by the
priest.
If you have some altar boys and these
priests molesting these kids and they
stay in the system,
the odds of them turning into molesters
themselves or it's extremely high.
Right?
What do you think,
uh,
why do you think people molest children?
Boy,
I think there's probably a whole host of
reasons for that psychological reasons,
but I think that a big part of it was
being molested themselves.
There's some enormous percentage of
people who have been molested,
who turned to become the very thing that
victimized them.
It's almost like they want to get back
at someone and best way to do the
attack,
the innocent.
It's the only way you can impart that
same har crazy.
It's insane.
It's also like a kind of weird dark
magic.
It's like,
why are,
why are there a certain percentage of
human beings that do that?
Kind of the weirdest,
most abhorrent thing.
Do you hear the,
um,
there's a really interesting radiolab,
I think episode that's basically about
these kids,
this kid who realized that he was a
pedophile,
like he,
that's what he wanted and he realized
he'd never offended.
Is that a reason why it's a few years
old,
but he realized he'd never,
he had never offended.
And so he went to his mother and was
like,
there's something wrong with me,
like I'm a pedophile or whatever.
It's like a teenager.
And so the mother tried to find
treatment for him but nobody would treat
him because it's such a deep taboo of
evil that people like,
I don't want to get involved in that.
I don't want to treat you and then have
you offended and then have it come back
on me.
So basically he'd never offended.
He had these desires and he couldn't get
help and he started this organization
for other people like him that it's like
a support group of pedophiles that have
never offended.
You can't.
If you've offended you're not eligible
for a membership in this group and you
can help each other not,
it's like pretty deep in the annals of
like with a weird dark web or whatever,
or I don't know where they find each
other,
but uh,
it's pretty crazy.
Have you seen the,
there's a,
there's a whole market that's being
developed where they're going to make
like artificial children on like,
um,
like a,
like a sex doll,
like a child sex doll.
And there's this argument that that
would prevent people from becoming
pederasts.
Wow.
That is crazy.
Like the ultimate iteration of
teledildonics is that it cures
pedophilia.
Well,
it's the same argument they would use
towards a anime,
anime,
pedophilia or any,
any sort of,
um,
you know,
cgi based pedophilia is that.
If you could look at child porn,
that's not real and no one's a victim of
it and your lock yourself in your room,
you could alleviate your desire to have
this thing,
but maybe that's true.
Problem with that is man,
there's a real argument that that's
feeding your desire to do that because
that's what happens with men when it
comes to regular pornography.
just what I was going to say,
that would only hold true if it wasn't
for the fact that you.
If you didn't see something important to
go,
I got to try that.
I think the problem is we're looking for
a solution like,
you know,
oh,
there's a fire,
throw water on it.
There's no like when it comes to people
and thinking especially like sexual
things and behavioral things,
like a dictum things.
people are messy.
Yeah.
There's a crazy ted talk.
I think it's a ted talk out there.
This woman who's worked with teenage sex
offenders like her whole career and she
basically says that we think of that.
It's at least with teenage sex
offenders,
which is like pedophilia,
teenage on younger pedophilia.
The cure and recidivism rate is,
it's extremely treatable,
right?
Like it's very,
very treatable,
but we look at that phenomenon as you.
Once you are that you are that forever
and you will always re-offend and
there's no hope and no going back from
it and it's not statistically that
doesn't hold water and her point is
basically like,
it is easier for us to think of these
people as monsters than to think of them
as sick.
People that could get better if we can
just say like throw them away.
They'll never be better
than we can kind of synthesize it into
our brain.
But in reality these are messy.
Like you said,
even bring that up.
What you just said.
You're a sympathizer,
right?
You know that these people are monsters
and I think the idea is that,
you know,
we were talking about spectrums like
there,
like say if you get a 100,000 people,
right,
what,
how many of those hundred thousand
people feel like they were born into the
wrong sex?
You know how many,
how many of those 100,000 people have
some bizarre sexual attraction to body
parts or to a underage people or to
older people,
you know,
vulnerable people.
There'S,
there's a bunch and what causes those
things,
but there's a host of different reasons,
but it's so messy and so complicated for
people to defend,
especially to defend pedophilia in any
way.
It's a radioactive.
Yeah.
You want to kill those people.
That's it.
That solution is killam,
killam,
black and white.
It makes sense.
Yeah.
Everybody in this,
in this makes every player in this story
makes sense where it doesn't make sense.
History.
Oh,
right.
Because they used to have different
views of.
It doesn't make sense that everybody
that was like,
you know,
he goes,
socrates,
plato.
I mean you go through the line.
They were all monSters,
so it was their quote.
I've never been able to verify it's
real,
but the.
They say the persian said a woman for
duty,
a boy for pleasure and a melon for
ecstasy.
Lou melon,
fuck a melonite gets.
They fucked him on it because it tastes
good.
That's ecstasy because it lived in the
desert.
I'm pretty sure they fucked a melon.
jesus,
why would you fuck a melon?
It's hard on the outside.
I think that would change your dick.
That doeSn't seem like a good move.
Unless she likes bevel the edges.
That's my fourth.
My fourth special.
Don't fuck them.
Melon
melon for ccs.
Oh wow.
That's so strange.
Yeah,
I mean that's a.
I mean that's what people said that have
gone over to Afghanistan to write.
A lot of soldiers have said that runs
rampant over there.
Right?
And that child sexual abuse can child
dolls keep pedophiles from offending?
One man thinks so.
He's been manufacturing them for clients
for more than 10 years.
Is there any images of these things?
Is it going to show it online?
But I could show you guys if you could
show us.
No,
thank you.
You don't want to see.
No,
I'll see.
I just want to be on record saying no
thank you.
Roll up to the website.
That's the japanese had to translate it.
Here we go.
Oh boy.
English.
To get a tor browser.
Oh
boy.
Okay.
All right.
Wow.
That's weird.
They're fucked up,
man.
You just got racist as fuck.
Forget about your cultural mean the
dolls.
Oh,
you mean the japanese.
Wait,
what did I do?
You said they're fucked up.
They are to mean the japanese.
But do you mean.
Oh no,
I meant the judge not so silently do
this,
this.
Let's turn this off.
Especially as a guy with daughters.
I'm not really.
Yeah,
that's a.
I don't have daughters.
Can you throw it back
up?
Actually wrote back.
That's how that's going to have a son
either
do any melons.
MelonS up there.
It's what we're looking at about 10.
It looks like maybe younger even.
I,
uh,
that was disturbing.
Um,
man.
And the ideas that somehow or another
that's going to be able to stop people
from molesting kids by fucking that
rubber doll or is it going to charge up
their desires even further?
I,
yeah,
that's a crazy.
I don't know.
I have no way.
No way to.
I wouldn't want to fuck a dog by the
way.
That's the number one argument against
pornography.
Pornography rather.
Prostitution.
Number one argument that I've ever heard
against it because I feel like a grown
woman,
she'd be like,
there's all sorts of levels of
prostitution,
like here's the level,
here's,
here's an acceptable level.
A woman who likes to give massages.
Say if you're a woman and you're a
massage therapist and you have a select
group of clients and you enjoy giving
those men massages,
you're giving them some sort of physical
pleasure with their body.
You can have the same sort of deal with
a bunch of people and give them sex,
right?
Sure.
And that's all it is.
It's just a in you like them.
They're your friends.
You hugged them,
they give you some money and you're.
Thank you.
We'll see you next tuesday.
You gonna keep your tuesday appointment.
Yeah,
yeah.
I'll see you tuesday.
The guy looks forward to tuesday,
caesar on tuesday.
They get together.
She,
you know,
she gives him a backrub.
She light some candles.
They have sex.
He gives her money.
That's to me,
that's a victimless crime.
One hundred percent,
but then you get into the idea of sex
slaves.
You get into the idea of indenture child
sex slaves and there's actually a
crazier argument.
I'm not crazy,
but more a more even more compelling
argument for the moral good of
prostitution,
which is that there are these
prostitutes that only sleep with a
severely disabled people.
Yeah,
and I heard this radio special on.
It was very interesting.
This guy,
he himself was a radio producer but also
had lou gehrig's disease and he said
it's very similar to pedophiles.
Actually.
We like to think of disabled people as
having no sex drive as when they became
disabled.
Their sex drive's were disabled as well,
and the reason we like to think of it
similarly,
we like to think a pedophiles as
monsters because that simplifies.
That is it's nice for us to think of
disabled people like not having
horniness because they can't get laid.
I mean if we're being frank,
there are certain levels of disability
that it's very difficult to find a
partner,
you know,
you're,
you're intense to look at or you're
drooling all over yourself,
but you're still just as horny as every
other person.
So there was this radio special of the
sex workers that go and they fuck or
jerk-off these severely disabled people
who are so they are so disabled they
can't even masturbate.
And it's like,
I heard that and I was just like,
I went from going like it.
Prostitution is something I sort of
agree with to like,
these people are heroes.
These are like miracle workers.
Yeah.
I mean it's not a whole lot different
than massaging those people that,
you know,
uh,
one of the key,
I don't know if you've ever heard of
rolfing,
you've heard.
so one of the best
therapies for injuries to recover,
it breaks up fascia and it's really
brutal.
Deep tissue massage that doesn't feel
good at all.
It's a very painful,
a massage inside of your mouth and your
nose to do that.
There's like a ralph 10 and one of the
10,
the 10 different treatments.
And one of the 10 is the soft palate of
your mouth inside of your nos inside
your nose.
Wow.
It's real intense.
Why do they do that?
I don't know.
Some theory.
I don't know if I'm going to fucking
just go on a theory and let you stick a
rod up my nose.
I know that it's their fingers.
Oh,
come on.
You're not even supposed to pick your
nose,
you know.
Well,
you're talking to a guy who's had nasal
surgery because my nose was broken so
many times.
I've deviated septum surgery where they
went in and they had a cut parts of my
nose out that calcified.
Oh jesus.
They're going to this gala.
Our structural integration knows work
for insight.
Yo,
that visual.
Yeah.
I think that's some asshole that wants
to stick their finger up.
Your nose doesn't make any sense.
Nasal doctors tell you not to pick your
nose.
Cause infections.
It's very close to the bloodstream.
The thIn,
the skin is very thin on the inside of
the nose.
That's why picking your nose is
dangerous because you can get infections
and infection goes right to your
bloodstream and straight to your brain.
Yeah.
Um,
uh,
we started.
Oh,
so rolfing.
So like what they do is,
I'm ida rolf,
the woman who invented rolfing.
I think that's her name.
No,
it's really a dog from the muppets.
I don't think that's off the dog.
I don't think the piano player.
No,
it's not the same role.
Okay.
All right,
go ahead.
I think the woman invented it because
her son had cerebral palsy and was one
of the best ways to alleviate some of
his mess muscle issues was this intense
form of manipulation because he'd become
so bound up by his disease that she had
figured out a way to loosen up the
tissue so they had more range of motion.
I found some great relief with that
stuff,
but it's ruthlessly pain.
Yeah.
I've had some rolfing done to.
It's,
it's,
it's nice,
but it's also awful.
it's great in its result.
But man,
it's brutal.
I wanted to make one final point about
that because I think I figured out how
to make my cultural appropriation point.
Uh,
I don't want to take us back too far,
but I think what we're,
what we're doing is like we came to a
good place with a dislike.
What we're talking about.
It's all about language,
right?
So cultural appropriation,
your immediate reaction is that's
absurd.
And some of the examples people use is
absurd,
but the,
the underneath the racism is just,
we're talking about racial
insensitivity,
we're talking about being sensitive and
if you try to just focus on that,
then you can get to like other reality
of what's happening.
And the original point I wanted to make
waS in this article I read about it,
it said that we often get locked on
these linguistic,
the boat that the concept floats in on
the absurd boat.
So like black lives matter is the
ultimate example you gave.
I just thought this was such a
fascinating point,
is like black lives matter is the name
of the organization that is there to
fight against police brutality and
killing of black kids.
Right?
And people react to the words,
right?
So people go,
what are you talking about?
Black lives matter.
All lives matter.
Blue lives matter.
And basically if you.
You don't acknowledge that it's black
lives matter too,
which is really obvious,
right?
You're fighting about the words black
lives matter where we haven't been
talking.
You've left the foundation principle
behind like a long time ago,
which is police brutality.
No one's even talking about police
brutality anymore.
Now they're just talking about the
language that you chose to call your
group.
So at any rate,
I think that was the thing I was trying
to say.
Make sense?
Look,
all of it makes sense.
If what is going on is people are being
racist,
right?
If someone is doing something for racial
and appropriation or sex or culture and
appropriation at the heart of it
involves racial insensitivity,
racist
insensitivity,
but there's a difference,
right?
Racist.
Theoretically,
racist is an.
Again,
racism is a word that doesn't have a lot
of use anymore either because you
described the same phenomenon of you
saying too,
like your black friend.
Like wow,
I didn't expect you to be so articulate.
You mean well,
right.
You mean you're trying to be polite or.
I don't like black people there.
They're bad.
These are the same.
It's the same word to describe both of
those things.
Right.
So in sensitivity is,
is not overt.
An aggressive racism.
Yeah,
I think,
yeah,
yeah.
It's insensitive.
Racism.
Like you're not being sensitive to the
possibility that you're saying something
offensive or just doing something
boringly dump.
Now I agree with you.
The logic is more important than that
the nap.
But I think you know,
the more aware we can all be about how
to not be a dick.
Yeah.
It's like people want to say,
you know,
you could never have all in the family
on tv today.
Could you imagine people would go crazy.
Well,
that's because we moved past that.
I mean that's what's going on.
What's going on is there's a process and
one of the things is disturbing to
people about trump and what's disturbing
to people about this new freedom to mock
jews are appointed them as the root of
all evil and then it's much more open
than it's been before,
is that we thought we got through that
and then slowly but surely the
demonization of individual groups and in
terms of like who are the bad guys and
who are the good guys and instead having
it been boiled down to activities and
behaviors and individual human beings
that have the problem.
Not giant groups of people that believe
in one god versus another god,
which is what it's been historically.
Right.
The idea is that as time goes on and as
people like my people,
the italians become so integrated that
you can't be racist about us anymore.
It doesn't work.
Right?
Totally.
I mean,
it really doesn't work.
It's one of the best examples of it.
Totally.
It's fascinating because there's so many
things that are there still and you're
like,
they don't have any charge or power
any longer.
Not only that,
there's so much gross behavior by
italian.
It just goes unchecked,
you know,
and I think the sopranos is probably
responsible for a lot of that.
I was in Italy last year and I was
walking home real late at night and I
saw this guy,
he's got his girlfriend up against the
car and he's fucking like going off on
her and I'm like this little like
liberal american boy,
like is somebody going to call the
police?
And then I kind of stood there for a
while longer and he's screaming in her
face and then I just look for about like
two or three minutes.
I go,
oh,
this is just some italian shit.
I just walked home.
I like realize like,
oh,
there's nothing happening here.
Oh yeah.
They used to.
That's what they used to do,
you know?
And they still do it over there.
When I was over there,
my driver,
we had this cab driver and this
motherfucker was a cartoon.
Oh,
he was driving and driving like a
maniac.
And then he would pause.
oh mama mia,
look at this girl's ass.
And no,
Italy iS so italian.
It,
there are parts of how italian it is.
That will boggle your mind like a dude
smoking a cigarette on a vest.
But with a girl sitting sideways and
everything is like the most italian
thing you could ever imagine.
Yeah.
It's,
it's funny because I went there with my
family and my wife was like,
oh,
so this is where you get your shit for
like from a group of eight people.
Uh,
Italy is the best.
Yeah.
The best place,
it's fun.
We went to the mall fee coast.
I'm all for incredible,
so good.
So pretty.
Doesn't even look real.
It's,
it's insane.
I mean Italy is like a jewel box.
It just everything.
any further into it you go.
The more pretty good heard.
CecIly is really beautiful too.
I never went on.
I haven't even either.
I went up to tuscany and I drove all
through there and me and natasha found
like this bath cities,
these cities where the romans would come
to bay.
Then it was like,
you know,
every time italian city has like a town
square,
this had a town pool in the center of it
and it was so cool and weird and there
was this big old mountain like mound of
sulphuric residue.
This like soft white mountain gets
called theosophy fossil bianco and it's
just big white mountain of like soft,
chalky,
sulphuric residue that the,
the,
the like the soda water has been fallen
on it for so long that it's carved these
pools into it and they're like little
hot tubs that you can get into on this
mountain and italy's bananas.
Wow.
We wanted to go to,
um,
what's the place where the volcano went
off and everybody does stromboli oh,
a pump,
a pump a I wanted to go to,
but we never got around to it.
I thought that would have been
fascinating to see what these people
just hanging out and all of a sudden
lava and ash covered everybody and
they've frozen their tracks.
Died.
Their pumping is a wild place for sure.
You know,
It's um,
it's also interesting to go to europe
because you realize how old everything
is.
oh,
these,
this culture's been around for thousands
of years here.
Will brings us back to the beginning,
which is the roman empire.
It's just like,
you look at the artifice,
the residue of the all the hugest
society
that has ever existed mean the coliseum
they,
they made.
They killed so many animals for sport.
They put certain animals out of business
like they extincted some animals.
Really?
which ones?
I don't know.
They don't,
they don't have them anymore,
But like certain kinds of animals that
they would important,
important,
important.
They're just like,
yeah,
we killed them all just for sport.
It's not for any other reasons.
When we were in the coliseum,
they were explaining where the,
um,
they had those elevators.
It would take the animals up from the
ground floor and open the floor up and
then the animals would pop through and
they would do battle with them,
but they were talking about how they had
to raise up the side of the fences
because the lower levels,
we're,
all the rich people sat larry and they
were getting jacked by lions.
The lions figured out how to jump up and
get the people that were at the top.
Fuck yeah.
We needed to get some lines back to get
those billionaires with their yachts and
just eat them.
Yeah.
How much money do you have to have to
put one point $5.
Billion of it into a boat.
So crazy.
I had a friend who bought a boat for
like $60,000 and he took her for one
ride,
crashed into the pier,
put it in the garage for two years and
then sold it for 20,000.
So he took a $40,000 boat ride.
Oh,
jesus christ.
Yeah.
That's what they say,
it's a hole in the water where you pour
money into right now,
but if you like to fish it.
The cool thing about boats is that when
you,
like,
if you save,
you have something,
you'd go out,
marina del rey in,
you just go out into the water.
You could kind of go wherever the fuck
you want.
Like there's no road.
Right?
But you can go where it's,
but you know,
it's all water so you can go left and
right and as long as you don't hit an
island you can kind of do whatever the
fuck you want.
Did you see that maiden voyage
documentary?
Was that it's about this 14 year old or
16 year old girl that sales around the
world by herself.
Oh yeah,
I heard about that.
So interesting.
Who the fuck are her parents?
I mean there are some northern european
danish,
like previous events,
white people,
white people that don't have poverty.
That's
poverty.
I mentioned that call when you land,
you should get some poverty.
Actually that'll give you a little bit
more to do with your life.
Well,
you gotta think that the negative
aspects of certain societies do create
some sort of a rebound effect from those
negative aspects.
No,
shit.
They didn't make rock and roll in
Sweden.
They didn't make hip hop and fucking
Denmark.
That's right.
They didn't make all these like
vaudeville and standup comedy.
I mean this all came from people of
oppression and that's why about
yourself.
Yeah.
I mean thinking about like you growing
up with a deaf mom being poor and all
that craziness that you went through and
you're a kid like that kind of all that.
It pushes something through.
It's totally true.
Yeah.
I wouldn't.
I wouldn't go back and have been raised.
Are rich with normal parents?
Not for a million dollars.
No way.
No,
not now.
Once you've already done it,
but I w I wouldn't have wanted it to
have been done in a different way.
I like the trauma will also,
you know that you made you,
well a lot of people helped you,
but you made yourself.
Whereas if your parents were trump,
you know,
or your parents were the rockefellers or
whatever,
and they gave you this monthly stipend.
No.
Fuck man.
Who are you then?
Who is trump?
He's the same.
He's the same version.
He started from nothing.
I mean he started from $2 million from 2
million bucks from his father who was
one of the richest people in upstate New
York.
And now who is he?
Is he.
What is he like when the lights are off?
I wish I could have a fucking a feed of
trump's brain.
When the lights go down,
it's probably chaos.
What is he thinking?
Is he like,
I'm killing it,
or is he like,
what have I done?
I think there's got to be both.
Yeah,
he's got to be a.
Well,
he doesn't drink.
He doesn't do drugs.
Right.
And I think there's got to be a part of
his brain that's pushing down the what
have I done?
And reinforcing,
doubling down on the I'm the greatest.
I'm the best.
I mean,
that's why I kept saying about his
inauguration.
Numbers are so many people were there
and even when they told him that it
wasn't the case,
he fought it.
Then when he kept parenting,
not just parenting to friends but doing
it to the news,
doing it to the press that he got the
largest number of electoral college
votes.
That's crazy.
It's psychedelic narcissism.
It's like it's so far out there.
It starts to seem like,
whoa,
you're bending reality and actually is
bending reality.
He's done.
He's done a fascinating job of just
making people not know what's real
anymore and no one knows what's real
anymore and Syria as the ultimate
example because it's unclear what
Israel.
They're like,
no one knows what the right thing to do
is.
Who are we attacking and why?
What are we trying to stop?
You sent bombs,
so the people that are fighting isis to
fight those people from doing chemical
warfare on their own people,
but then we also were fighting isis with
them and then it's just the whole thing.
You're just like,
I give up you ron.
Paul was saying that the chemical attack
doesn't make sense,
so certain certain republicans are
actually looking at ms dot ron paul.
Technically republicans more libertarian
than anything,
but they're looking at it and saying
like this.
This might not even been real.
I mean,
I just.
I heard this great thing about how no
one in Israel believes that rabin was
killed by yigal amir,
the jewish guy like that.
They,
they believe in that.
Basically hearing a conspiracy theory
that widely believed in a country that
isn't my own made me realize how wildly
desperate for conspiracy theory everyone
is.
Like somehow the distance where it was
like,
oh,
it's Israel.
It's not really me.
Made me go like,
oh,
this is so interesting.
Like everybody wants to believe it
wasn't one hour until they were saying
that the chemical attack by assad was
not real.
Even though assad has done gas based
chemical attacks on his own people
before and his father did before him.
Somehow this one was like,
no,
no.
This is fake.
It might be fake.
That's what's so crazy and mind bend
day.
It might be fake and yet I don't buy any
conspiracy theories anymore because I
know how desperate people are to believe
them.
Well,
this was the same scenario that led
obama
to make that speech saying that we need
to go into Syria and the whole american
people went fuck that because we were
deep in the Iraq war,
deepen the Afghanistan war,
and that was when this,
I think that was 2013 or 14,
but trump made quotes.
It's crazy that he tweeted like,
what does the us have to gain for going
into Syria?
We should be America first and then
winds up acting almost instantaneously.
It happens.
People keep dropping these,
like you said,
this bombs at trump's feet like he cares
about intellectual coherence or
hypocrisy.
He doesn't care.
He's a fucking brat trapped.
He's trapped in a corner of a maze and
he's going like,
what the fuck do I do?
Oh,
I'll just do this.
It's so.
It's so transparent,
like 35 percent approval rating.
Everything is collapsing under your own
weight.
You have the house and the senate and
you can't get anything done.
No one likes you.
You're the worst,
so what do you do?
You fucking make something explode.
It's just such a terrible recipe of
something actually goes wrong.
Oh yeah.
Like Syria as a minor issue.
No one died.
Totally bomb.
Some airfields.
They ruined some.
Some ground.
I agree.
Ruined some air ships planes.
But what happens if something really
goes down and that guy is.
That is the figurehead,
that is the difference between the roman
empire and this empire is that the roman
empire didn't have the power to press a
button and destroy like half the
countries on earth and we do.
So that's the scary part.
Come to the comedy store that saturday
night.
Yeah.
Let's wrap it up with depressing.
I'm doing.
I'm doing a show on comedy central.
I should probably mention.
Yeah,
you briefly mentioned it earlier,
but tell everybody what it is.
April 18th we debut.
It's called problematic.
Yeah.
I'm excited about it.
Why do you call it problematic and why
you look at hitler?
Because iT's problematic.
We're basically.
I mean it doesn't even look like you.
That's what a weird photo you don't
think.
I think it's.
I think I look cute if you do look cute.
Thank you.
Well you look like you're 19 years old
with your mom.
Yeah,
it's still have my deaf mom.
I'm still running embarked trans.
Um,
basically it's a theme.
Every week is a theme of some of the,
you know,
the,
the undercurrents of society.
We're talking,
we're not talking politics.
We're talking about like the,
the tectonic plates underneath them,
you know,
so cultural appropriation,
how the internet is changing our brain,
the dark web,
all these kind of like,
you know,
a lot of the fun stuff that you'd like
to go to to,
you know,
just these big,
big concept,
big ideas.
And it's like,
it's a talk show where.
Oh.
And the other cool thing is it's very
donahue.
So we'd go out into the audience and let
people ask questions and get on up and
say their piece.
And so you do it in front of a live
crowd from the live audience.
And so some of it's done in the field
and then you bring it back and show it
to the audience.
And like,
so like we,
this week we're,
we're doing the how,
the,
how technology is changing us.
We have this guy nick carr that wrote
the shallows on and um,
and it's a couple of comedians to make
it fun and funny and uh,
basically,
uh,
every week as a different topic and a,
and we ask a question and hopefully we
get to the bottom of it.
Did you come on sometimes though?
I will love to.
What do you want me to do?
I don't know yet.
What do you think you would?
Yeah,
I'll send you some.
I'll send you all the topics and we'll
figure something out.
Yeah.
Cool.
Yeah,
it's,
uh,
it's perfect for,
it's perfect for people that like this
show because it's like real
conversations.
It's not like it's an actual.
I think people are desperate for that.
And I think that's,
I think you,
you were actually kind of ahead of the
curve on the real conversation thing,
but I think people are like podcasts in
general are.
I think it's so interesting that we are
simultaneously like making technology
and entertainment shorter and shorter
and shorter and shorter and there's
things like your show where there like
two hour episodes.
It's like at the same time people are
driven to distraction.
They're also like trying to.
They're desperate to get some depth and
uh,
hopefully this will will find.
Well it just fills a different,
a different void that's a
available in entertainment,
especially when people are driving.
Like if you're driving for long periods
of time,
which a lot of people listen to this
right now are doing,
hi everybody.
How you doing?
Drivers tune in if you're on a plane
flight and it's going to take you 14
hours,
downloaded a bunch of podcasts.
That stuff is the best.
It's like you can just sit there and
chill and it allows you to enrich your
mind because you,
you listen to these conversations and
you feel like you're there and you,
you also know this is like the thinnest
sort of organization available as bare
bones as it gets.
This is leanne.
Yeah,
but it's,
that's the part of it's beauty.
I mean that's,
and that's the difference between making
a show and podcasts and podcasts and
it's awesome because you can find the
colonel in minute 48 and you're like,
oh,
I found what that
it was about,
like we've done a couple of times in
this conversation,
go back to things and see how they're
connected,
but we don't have an executive standing
over our shoulder telling us to hit all
the data points.
Right.
So I hopefully,
and by the way,
comedy central has been,
and I'm not just saying this is a
company man,
they've been cool about saying like,
go get weird.
They kind of have to know.
Yes,
I totally agree.
They're locked into the spot like,
oh my god,
everyone's going away.
there's no one left on television.
Exactly.
And they have,
they have south park,
which is the best.
And then they have [inaudible],
which is a monster and they don't have
much else.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They got another period.
My lovely wife.
so what is that?
Oh,
you've never seen it.
It's really funny.
Is it on right now?
It's on,
yeah,
it will be.
Its third season is the summer of.
I wrote and produced that show for the
last few years,
but it's a spinoff for more than a year.
Yeah.
This,
it'll be third season.
this,
uh,
I mean there's too much tv,
joe.
There's just is too much tv used to be
when a comic had a show,
it was a big deal.
I know.
It's crazy.
A comment getting his own show is now a
comic doing like a doing a comedy
central presents or,
or premium blend.
You know,
it's like the same equation and the
young comics are so funny because
they're like,
they think they deserve a show and it's
like,
really?
It's used to be me thinking I deserve to
go to like montreal is like,
I'm thinking where's my network show?
fuck you.
That's so weird.
It's weird.
What a weird time man.
It definitely is,
but it's a weird time.
But you don't podcast too,
right?
I do.
Yeah I do.
Oh I still need to come on to.
I'll do it.
Yeah.
Uh,
it's called the hound tall discussion
series and it's basically what led to
this a tv show on comedy central,
which was that we were getting,
we get one expert on and it's in front
of a hound tall instead of the town
hall.
Yeah,
yeah.
The little play on words that we expect
people to remember that no ill advise,
bad name.
I'm willing to admit that,
you know,
about three episodes in.
I said to them,
the listeners,
I was like,
I'm willing to change his name.
I'm thinking that stupid.
They all were like,
no,
we like it now.
so don't listen to them in the first
place.
They're the ones who are willing to
listen to it with a crazy name.
So we basically get an expert on and we
have that person tried to give a talk in
this field of expertise while comics
riff over it.
So it's like mystery science theater
meets a ted talk kind of.
Oh,
that's cool.
Yeah.
So every,
every.
So that's kind of what led to the tv
shows that every week is a different
topic and this is,
every episode is a different topic.
So you enjoyed doing this conversation
with thing?
It was fun.
Yeah,
it's fun.
I,
I'm into like,
you are.
I'm into like big ideas and big
conversations.
It's harder to have big conversations in
bite size,
you know,
use it half,
half hour,
half hour.
I'd like it to get to be an hour if,
if,
if all goes well,
I'd like that to happen.
Especially when you're dealing with
things like cultural appropriation.
I know just the opposing sides,
they're going to take more than 15
minutes.
Exactly.
It's electric,
it's electric.
The full tapings have been really fun
and electric and then you have to
squeeze them into 22 minutes.
So we're going to be releasing a bunch
of extended,
uh,
stuff lIke we had mc search on.
It was really a great conversation and
had mc search on to talk cultural
appropriation that real so real.
Did he keep it really real?
I mean,
this is a bit.
Yeah.
Mc search used to have the worst talk
show in the history of the known
universe and it was so bad they will
play clips of it on opiod anthony and
clips of him talking about where we're
going to keep it real y'all.
But thIs conversation I had with search
was so first of all,
I love search and he was.
So our conversation about appropriation,
I used to love him.
Third base.
yeah,
right.
He's like the original guy and we were
talking with like a 1981 white rapper
about cultural appropriation when it's
like a really cool,
really awesome.
Well he appropriated the whole deal.
He got a black wife and the whole deal.
He went,
yeah,
he went deep.
He went to duke.
He saId something so funny in this
interview I was asking is it different
that when white people appropriate just
we were talking about it's different
with black people appropriate versus
when white people appropriate and he
goes,
he thinks for a second.
He goes,
well white people as a whole or the
devils of society.
Like I did not think you were about
this.
He's white.
I mean,
it was just so bizarre,
but anyway,
uh,
so every week is a different topic and a
smart guy.
I think he's a very smart guy.
One of the best storytellers I've ever
met.
Really.
You got to hear his story about how mc
hammer tried to have him killed.
It's one of the greatest stories.
It's one of the greatest stories of all
time.
Is that a real.
Oh,
It's amazing.
It's on my pop,
my old podcast that I did with neil
brandon,
the champs,
his episode,
a mc searches episode.
It's on there and it is one of the
craziest stories you will ever hear in
your life.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's real.
Mc hammer tried to have him killed.
Listen.
hey,
listen to the story.
I mean,
yes,
you want me to tell you the story?
I can tell you a verse,
a quick version.
Okay.
basically,
he did an a song where they dissed mc
hammer's mom,
right?
Oh,
jesus.
For some lyrical reason.
I mean it didn't.
And mc hammer got angry and called the
head of the crips in la to put a
contract out on their life.
Right?
So Russell Simmons hears about it,
right,
and they are at third base is in a
flight from New York to California and
Russell Simmons hears about it and it's
like,
oh my god,
they're gonna kill third base,
right?
And so he calls the head of the crips
and it's like,
you have to take this,
uh,
you have to dead this,
this contract,
please don't kill my clients or
whatever.
and so The guy,
the head of the crips is like,
I will end this hit on third base,
but only if you can get me tickets to
the emmys,
uh,
to the grammy's and sitting next to
Michael Jackson and Russell Simmons is
like,
oh my god,
okay.
And then he calls Michael Jackson
through some crazy series of events and
somehow gets some Michael Jackson and
Michael Jackson says,
okay,
I'll let him sit next to me if blah,
blah,
blah happens.
I don't know what it was.
Some other weird twist.
Bring some robot.
Fuck kid does
go to the future.
FinaLly sees kids bringing them back.
And then third base,
by the way,
they have no idea they're in the air.
They're flying while all of this,
like weird machinations are happening,
they land and meeting them at the gate
is a crip,
a high level like lieutenant crip.
Right.
And he's like,
stay with me.
There's a contract on your life and the
only way that you'll live through this
trip is if you stay right next to me.
So they're walking through la and these
trips are coming up who haven't because
it's like the crips,
you know,
they don't have like a structure.
Right,
exactly.
So these trips are like roll up and the
lieutenant will be like a crip crip,
you know,
hand sign,
stand down and the crip will be like
about to kill him.
And then would go,
oh,
thank god search.
I'm a big fan man.
Right on.
Like,
oh my god.
Jesus christ.
That's the craziest story.
Mc hammer jumps the gun.
Huh?
A little crazy there.
I mean indeed that I don't know if it's
true,
but I know that he told that story.
Wow.
Anyway,
let's leave it at that.
Cool.
So when did your show start?
April 18th.
Ten pm after tosh.
The monster.
That's um,
next.
Yeah,
next thursday,
thursday,
thursday.
Next thursday is our first episode.
Oh,
right after [inaudible] sweet spot too.
Yeah,
the banking on moesha.
I hope so.
I'm banking on me too.
Well,
thanks brother.
Let's do this more often.
I'll do next.
Yes,
please,
please.
Thanks joe.
That's awesome.
Hi everybody.
That was awesome.